[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and carcasses viewer discretion is
advised it's a cool breezy afternoon
there's some cloud cover in the perfect
conditions for a young male Steinbach to
roam around the open plains of Juma this
is safari live
standing by
five four three two
[Music]
good afternoon and welcome to our sunset
Safari my name is Tristan on camera
today our what sins are socks monkeys
who has decided this afternoon to wear
his very finest pair of socks which
we'll get into just now now remember we
are coming to you live which is hashtags
fired live on Twitter the YouTube chat
if you want to be able to chat to us or
you want to ask any questions about
what's going on now since uh since we've
started with an S and the steelbook i
think socks are a perfect time to come
out the clouds are starting to break
there was a bit of sunshine aliases sins
has decided to whip out his best and
finest pair of socks this off soon come
on sins a socks out I did my socks this
morning you've got to do your socks now
here we go
so sins ur has got his socks out and
they are very patriotic socks look at
that we've got the South African flag
socks so we've got patriotic socks
this afternoon we also have another
member of the crew driving around with
us this afternoon and you might have
noticed his little eyes sticking out in
the dashboard that is pg me emoticon
speaker that gives us a lot of
entertainment and well it's just for a
bit of vibe in us as Megan says before
we go out and drive in the parking lots
we kind of play a bit of music and get
ourselves into the swing of things so PG
is riding along this afternoon and we
thought you look quite cool under the
dashboard with his little white eyes
poking out so he's going to be riding
and hopefully he'll bring us some good
luck because well there's lots of
potential this afternoon we're going to
probably just do our time lapse quickly
hello little male skin work you very
relaxed are you going to run away from
us or stay there how relaxed is the
steam book that's ridiculous he's not
running anyways this is my piece of
grass I'm not going to run away and see
he's got his nose down sniffing I wonder
if he's looking for his female companion
who's around they also mating at this
time of the year so much like the darker
they're also looking to mate and to find
females so that's maybe why he's
sniffing so much maybe he's picking up
the scent of where a female has walked
and that's going to lead him to a mating
opportunity
TI smells all the little branches it's
not actually eating maybe that's also
why he's not running for us too
preoccupied with the scent of a lady to
worry about this big
that is close by and like I said it's
probably the most relaxed in what we've
seen in a long time no way
scared of us at all but I was saying
that this afternoon is full of promise
and hope we had hasanat twin dams this
morning in Coomer with her hubs around
us north of the lodge and the high
Nadine was active so lots of different
things that we can try and schedule for
this afternoon what I want to try and do
is probably head towards the in kuma
lioness and her fluffy little Cubs and
see if we can get a view of them this
often to start with because remember
that sighting will close when it starts
to get dark which will be fairly early
this afternoon with the card cover that
we've got and then we gain to hit
southwards towards probably husana and
try and get a little bit more time with
him in the last 2 3 minutes that we had
this morning apparently he was left a
very sleepy all curled up in a tiny
little ball in the same place and there
was lots of alarm calls apparently to
the north of him so I'm pretty sure
tumbles around and I wonder if we're not
going to get Tambor husana 2.0 this
afternoon so it will head in that
direction a little bit later to see if
we can find the two young gentlemen of
Juma but before we do all of the wet
sand we get to interested in all of the
other things what we need to do is we
need to go and do our time lapse so I'm
going to take sensor to do our time
lapse so we can do that and then we'll
have that out the way and then we can
get into the serious stuff now I believe
a lot of you are very very fond of sins
Oh socks I know they are patriotic I do
like them too since we've done a
sterling it for today buddy well then so
it's always good to be patriotic and I'm
quite enjoy those one so those are
fantastic and yes Pucci is a wonderful
addition to the team he's puts right in
as you can see he's got a perfect space
it's almost like wendy was designed to
house poogie on the dashboard so
peih-gee sits there he's got his big
white eyes and he just watches over what
goes on and hopefully he'll like I say
we'll bring us lots of luck the other
nice thing about Bujji is if we have
some bird calls and things like that now
I no longer have to kind of hold a phone
to my head and pretend like I am kind of
concentrating on looking at the backend
of my phone I can play it from here and
poogie will emanate that sound towards
all of you into the camera and it will
be much easier for all of us involved so
he's a good addition I'm not sure if it
to he or she it haven't decided Megan he
or she Lou I don't know anybody not sure
we'll have to think about that
he I think he making goes she I go he
synthesis our Megan it's a he Lou says
he saw Megan you've been outvoted three
to one we went so there we go
crew G is a boy so he's going to bring
us some luck this afternoon I'm can feel
it in my bones
okay Kanpur make him play a song I can
feel it in my fingers I can feel it in
my toes
isn't it something like that yes I think
there's a song that goes something like
that now I won't be the only one out
this afternoon it seems like we might
have the Mara as well in full force it
sounds like Brinkley or Smith is growing
down the hill and so is Taylor and I
think Jamie's also might even be out
somewhere near a river somewhere and
crossing that way so oh no PG don't fall
so it seems as though we're going to
have a full crew out this afternoon
which will be wonderful and I'm pretty
sure that it's going to be very
spectacular given that this morning was
anything well if we get anything to go
by but this morning it's going to be
really quite wonderful what's wrong
sensor I'm supposed to park closer no we
want to see your socks so sins are
things that I was part closest that he
can hide his socks but there's no chance
and you can see since there's a colorful
character not only does he have colorful
socks he's got a bright orange jersey
nice bright green t-shirt so he really
is sporting some colors this afternoon
and he is certainly adding some vibrance
to our day so fashion guru my certainty
sensor you are the fashion guru once
again standing by is tree waving there
we go so this is gonna become a thing
now it's no longer the thumb of the
afternoon it's going to be the socks and
since our waving at the marula tree
because we keep doing to him but he
certainly is looking very very spiffy
this afternoon and he's going to be
impressing whatever animal we come
across hopefully they will also increase
she ate the brightness and bits of
joyfulness that since I was bringing to
this afternoon's proceedings I certainly
have enjoyed it
now well done sensor that was very
quickly becoming quicker than say but
this rates which is a mean feat so very
good job now I believe that I was saying
Lamarr a team out and that brain clear
Smith is out and well he's raring to say
hello to all of you so let's go across
him and see what his plans are for the
afternoon my name is on camera today and
we're going to go try find that female
cheetah that we were so desperately
after yesterday but unfortunately the
rain put an end to that now we're
actually going down the road that was a
river and looking a little bit drier
today and if we fail with the female
cheetah we'll probably head back towards
this area and see if we get any luck
with the gamma pride very exciting we
got going a little bit late this
afternoon we had a bit of early rain
fortunately it wasn't too heavy so we
are able to get out and let's hope the
rain that stays away now Jamie is all
the way on the other side of the river
and hopefully she might have some luck
with the amani girls or even possibly
the Bella shaaka boys there's no other
miny girls a pair of female cheetah
and the village soccer boys are
coalition of six male lions whoa here we
go the first bit of fun
hold on
easy desert
remember hashtag is Safari live if you
have any questions from us we would love
to hear from you it is a gorgeous our
theme Taylor is going to be heading and
down towards the southeast seeing if she
can maybe catch up I heard there might
be a possibility of some wildebeest
crossing around look Hart crossings so
fingers crossed there that it might be
some bull these back in the Triangle
shortly
so we're gonna keep marching that
towards so they're the Southwest so the
complete opposite direction to Taylor
we're going to move along against
allah-allah escarpment and see if we can
have any luck there with that female
cheater of course it's also a great
sausage Pride country
Oh lots of muddy spots yeah so I'm gonna
concentrate on where to go and and how
not to get stuck while we do that sounds
like trailer has got a special treat for
you before I even introduced myself
we're gonna lose sight of this Reiner
unfortunately they're quite a few cars
yes so I think let's have a little look
at the Rhino first and then once we have
to reposition of the nozzle introduce
myself to all of you but isn't this
fantastic isn't this incredible there we
go you can see someone's head and screen
it's very crowded yeah hello everybody
my name is saya and on camera with me
today is we're gonna go with cuts Roy
Craig and be good I think we're gonna
make that stick aka Batman sometimes
people call him Craig but not really no
this is live this is interactive this is
happening right now from the Mara
triangle in Kenya and we're very happy
to have you so if you have any questions
for us to remember hashtag did I say
that already
hashtag Safari though I think I may have
said that a RHIB it doesn't matter and
you can chat us on the YouTube chat I'm
trying to figure out how we're going to
get a view of these rhinos because we
can't really go off-road here it's a
high high usage area so we've got to
stick to the tracks and there's many
cars in front of us and I don't know
everything you see praying me see if I
can do a little bit of positioning
but we'll try how's that get through
these two cars I'll go a little bit more
there we go look how incredible that is
now the two of them yet one was most
certainly a male I didn't really get to
have another proper look at the other
one but it could be either way it could
be oh there we go we can have a look on
the left this will give us a chance to
zoom in double-check well yes that looks
very much like a female so it is a male
and a female that have obviously joined
up perhaps this lass is coming into
Easter's and the male is perhaps
starting up in the courtship process
very cool to see I've only seen rhinos
mating once before and white rhino it's
not even black runners so wouldn't that
be quite exciting and it's the first
time I've seen them out in the open like
this this is really really amazing oh my
goodness you won't believe our like a
gap has opened up Wow so we're just
gonna be a little bit patient one more
vehicle is moving and then we're just
gonna let them reverse and then we're
gonna jump back onto the track Shane
we're gonna dip flat not we're gonna
steal the sneak spot
and we're gonna stay on the track to
okay we're gonna pass back this so they
keep walking away from us but that's
okay
and we're gonna keep our distance we're
actually not gonna follow them for too
long
and the reason for this is because our
plan is to head to the far west where
rumblings from I don't know harbouring
gets all his Intel but brent has
whispered to me that apparently there's
some will to be sort of crossed back
from the Mara National Reserve back into
the triangle so we gotta go see if we
can find them there are lots of lines
down in that area so it could be quite
exciting will tonight be the day that I
get to see my first tank down from start
to finish in the Mara because can you
believe it I have not seen a kill yet
not that it's necessarily my favorite
thing but um it's still quite
interesting to learn about the various
hunting techniques of the different
lines using the different areas so
that'll be quite nice but I thought it
would be a great way to start our day
off with one of the endangered species
of Africa and you can see they're living
quite well here they're nice and healthy
there's lots of vegetation for them to
browse on and you can see that these
runners have actually well a part of
research they've got notches in their
ears so they were obviously darted and
blood samples were taken and I'm sure
they have their own ID somewhere hidden
safe it's very cool there Wow and I
really hope you're taking as many
screenshots as you can because it's not
often that we get to see them out in the
open for such a long time either
absolutely beautiful
and I could spend all day with these
animals one of my favorite things to do
down in the Eastern Cape under sit and
watch them a huge horse fan are you
wondering how long are they pregnant for
you just wondering you glad to wonder as
much as you like well the gestation
period for a black rider
is just a month less than the white
rhino so it's for 15 months it's quite a
long time white rhinos 16 months and but
really it's it's so close I mean what's
a month
they've been wallowing as well they look
like they've obviously sat in a bit of
mud during the day
another up and feeding isn't this great
now James how long is the courtship
process for a black rhino I'm trying to
think and the reserve that I worked with
actually and he had males who didn't
have any females what we did and
unfortunately she died of natural causes
not from poaching or anything so I
wasn't able to witness that courtship of
a black rhino and I wouldn't imagine it
would be I need a couple of days maybe
three to five days or so and maybe quite
similar to the white rhino and I'll have
to have a little look I did see quite a
few black rhinos in the sabi sand in the
South but they were so skittish as
always at a distance and all charging
through a lion sighting
I just suppose is pretty good how's that
scenery all those tall trees the grass
is lovely and green fallen trees there
really is stunning archer well on the
fact that you've also got two black or
white - how's that - black white rhinos
walking to your screen look at those
pointy lips perfect for nibbling off the
leaves
I wonder what shrub they're eating over
here has anyone ever seen their round
nose when they eat euphorbias it's
something that I used to watch them do
quite a bit it's one of their favorite
foods in fact that you'd quite a large
amount of the euphorbia and that is
present in this area - no Larry you said
that they are beautiful and they're
prehistoric looking there are rhinos
haven't really changed much in their
design for millions of years so if they
really are one of the prehistoric
creatures archaea always armor-plated
but what we said they are going to have
to move off from here we've got a long
way to go still to get to the
southwestern corner of the triangle and
hope to find some wildebeest which would
be nice because I've seen a total of 12
wildebeest today and they were up on the
escarpment and that beautiful oh she's
got a bit of a he's got a bit of a split
yeah my favorite we recognise him
right
I'm going to see you all a little bit
later hopefully once I've arrived at my
destination I'm going to send you all
the way to South Africa now - dear
Tristan and I wonder if there are any
clouds looming in the sky there are some
clouds looming in the sky tailing akuti
but they are fairly innocuous at the
stage they bit splits part but sort of
broken up there's nothing really too
threatening in these clouds so I don't
think we're gonna get too much more
raining it was just that little bit that
we had this morning which was really not
enough like I say it's even settled the
dust after the dryness that we've had
over the last few months so at this
stage then we're gonna have nice weather
the soft and at least the wind has
dropped so the difference between
yesterday and today and why probably
today has been a little more successful
in terms of the types of animals that
we're seeing and then and the sort of
crop more species that are there or what
we're seeing is because the wind is down
so if the soon as the wind gets up a lot
of the animals try and find cover we got
lucky that we had the income of Pride
and that the sticks made a kill but if
we didn't have that it would have been
quite a difficult day at the office but
today no wind and we're seeing that the
leopards are out because I believed in
Ghana was seen this morning quarantine
was seen this morning husana was seen
this morning there was tracks for Tomba
as well so there's a lot of lipids
moving around and hopefully that means
that we will find them at some point
this afternoon as well and I'm right
near where this lioness was this morning
buttons you are asking about the Buffalo
if they came in to Juma unfortunately
not what happened with the buffalos they
went back into Manya Leyte so they
crossed waste into Manya lady but I've
just heard the update now that they've
come back again into buffers look and
they are slowly kind of moving in an
easterly direction now in terms of how
far they are away from the boundary
they're not they're about 800 to 900
meters north of the boundary itself and
there's no visual from our boundary with
them but I believe the herd is big big
big the guys say it's a very big herd so
I don't know exact
the Owlman using it but they say very
big which I'm hoping means at least 300
plus in that herd which is good news now
the interesting part about it is the way
that they walking they're about to walk
themselves into an unknown pride of
lions that is hanging around in Buffalo
right on the money lady boundary at the
moment call and they think it might be
the telemetry's which is the first time
I've heard of them in a long long time
apparently there's three sub adult males
that are around so two and a half three
years old and then there's some younger
Cubs around a year old and then three or
four line is something like that so
you're interesting to see how many they
are and to see what the actual story is
and whether or not they walk straight
into those lines and if those lines then
push the Buffalo hood southwards back
towards us which will be quite nice
right no let's see there's the termite
mound over there so I'm hoping she's
moved slightly out of where we had her
this morning because this morning wasn't
so pleasant where she was lying it was
really quite dense it was nice when the
Cubs were suckling because we could see
their little faces and we could watch
them moving around but I'm hoping that
this afternoon she's moved a little bit
she's gotten herself into a place where
we can see her quite nicely and that the
Cubs will be there as well
I have an idea that you might have left
in these cool conditions like we see now
she might have moved on and if that's
the case then we're gonna be leaving the
area immediately
with these Cubs we're not here to try
and stress them out in any way we just
want to come and view them with mom and
if mom's not sure then that's the end of
that I'm afraid and we have to leave the
area and leave them to themselves
okay so doesn't look like mommy's home
at this stage so when we go forward a
little bit
mm I don't think she's yep once you just
check around slightly because there she
is I can see it in Co Senza now if you
want to see what camouflage is like on a
line do you see which is you see how
long it takes Enzo to spot this but
since oh if you go that big tall tree in
front of me right over there is where
she's sitting in the long grass
so she's just can see her face ever so
slightly much from your angle be a bit
tough but if you zoom in for me just
over there you'll see just how
camouflage this line is is go go go go
go a little bit up to your left up up
and there she is you see her just behind
the trees there miss her back and her
head incredible it's amazing
the camouflage of a line is you can see
why they're difficult to spot sometimes
but luckily she puts her head up first
and that's why we were able to see her I
wonder if the little Cubs are the site
or if she's left him behind me here in
the drainage and she's now gonna start a
movement back towards the in Karuma
pride and back towards the west where
the rest are but it would be nice if the
little cubbies are our chair because
it's going to be very open and we will
get a nice view of those little ones
from here these she's around I mean it's
better that she's around she might do
one last suckle but I don't see any
signs of the Cubs and also I should be
in first year not in third year
otherwise we're going to stall
the little Cubs I don't think are here
we would have seen little heads popping
up already so I think they behind me and
back at the den sites where she was
suckling them and she's now starting her
movement back towards the rest of the
pride so there we go she's just lying on
her own and is taking it a little easy
I'm sure she's been suckling them she's
groomed them she's made sure that they
well fed and is making sure that they're
going to be okay and once they're
alright they fed they groomed looked
after then she's going to now start like
I say heading back to the pride to be
able to see if she can go and get some
nutrients for herself
remember these are cool ones are going
to you drink from her and they're going
to absorb a lot of the nutrients that
she's able to produce and therefore
she's gonna have a tough time of it and
she's starting to yawn which means I
think she's gonna start moving already I
don't think it's gonna be too long that
she's gonna be up and going
man oh you want to know how long until
the Cubs join the pride permanently
probably another I would say six to
eight weeks until they'll be joining the
pride and moving around and even then
they'll only join four caucuses in terms
of actually walking with the pride
generally it's at about six months that
they'll start to kind of move with the
pride all the time and there we go up
she gets you can see she's a little on
the skinny side which is because she's
having to move a lot more than the rest
of the pride she's having to go back and
forth probably fine she's also not
getting as much nutrients because she's
missing out on some of the kills and so
it's a tough life being a mom but if she
goes now she's going to start striding
her way I think back towards the west
and towards where she came from last
night so it's going to be a long walk
back that way unless the Cubs are hidden
somewhere there but I don't think so
spark so you're asking what time they
usually hunt well there's no specific
time for our liens or leopards or any
other cats to hunt they're opportunistic
animal to opportunistic animals which
means that they will hunt as soon as
they can when they can any opportunity
that comes along they will take it
whether that be nice day sunrise sunsets
hot cold doesn't matter they just hunt
whenever they can and whenever an
opportunity presents itself so it'll be
could be now she might start hunting if
she sees an Impala by herself you never
know she might try and hunt it by
herself but in all likelihood she's
probably gonna go to the rest of the
pride and they'll then want to start
hunting this evening so we saw last
night when we got to the inn Coomer
pride around sunset that's when they
woke up and started to move but she's
definitely left the Cubs now the Cubs
must be in the den they must be happy
there and it's okay we got to see them
this morning and I'll be interesting
just to follow her along I don't think
we're gonna be able to keep her for all
the time because she's gonna cross a
very bad drainage at some point so we're
going to just follow her anyway though
and see how she goes and whether or not
she goes all the way to the west because
that's going to be a very very long way
to get to where that is now while I
follow these all her let's go back to
Branson see how he's doing on his quest
for some of the tawny cats what we went
looking for cheetah and we've come
across lions - lovely ladies of the
sausage pride as I said you never know
what you're going to find and as you can
see there's some potential meals in the
background walking through some zebra in
the distance now I haven't seen these
girls stand up here so I'm not sure the
skinny there oh wow hungry there there
goes madam mccurdy rushing past us at a
rate of knots nice you guys here we go
let's have a look yeah you can see
Taylor here she goes
I thought you often we actually see each
other out our check because it is so big
and we cover such vast distances that
that we can sometimes go a lot a couple
of days without actually seeing another
vehicle down on the valley floor by
Taylor now Taylor said is heading down
to the southeast and she's hoping that
some of the wildebeest have cost around
and look out hill and I think we're
gonna sit we're gonna stay local we're
gonna sit with these girls I think Jamie
had the one has ever kill a few days ago
but there could be hungry they do have
quite a few Cubs to feed last counter he
was nine in total between the different
lionesses of the sausage ride so we've
only got to dine this is yeah the Cubs
are probably closer towards the
escarpment there's a couple of others a
few spots that they're really likes you
like to hide the Cubs in and who knows
and maybe they'll hit that way or maybe
no wait for the zebra to come a bit
closer now he is there are quite a lot
of zebra around so there's by no means a
shortage of food for the sausage bride
although some babies as well in the
distance we got all happening yeah okay
so yeah elephants missed just a little
southwest of us
you can hear lots of wonderful sounds
apart from the wind lots of frogs after
that massive amount of rain we had
yesterday you can hear some endorphin
paddle frogs here a natural toad
somewhere Oh
Ferg's found a bird oh yeah guys it was
a looked like your green or wood
Sandpiper I didn't get a good enough
look what's his figures found odd you
found a frog I'll show you out of water
this is God he is wandering there zebras
not see the lioness not if they're not
if they're not moving if they're sitting
still like they are at the moment in
that distance they're probably not gonna
spot the Lions you never know zebra
argument going on over there the back
with that little group in the family and
discussion about where to go now that'll
be the stallion there we go kick kick
kick
there'll be the stallion trying to sort
out his ranks so with zebras it's
absolutely fascinating the oldest female
must lead and if she doesn't and one of
the younger females tries to lead he
will bite and kick the the rest of the
harem into place so even once that all
those females were out in front and
there will be a set order that he likes
the rest of the herd to follow in and
the stallions were generally bring up
the rear but it's not always the case
but quite often the case especially when
they're moving in straight lines and
there will be lots of at the back is
he's sorting someone else again
someone's out of place kicking and
biting making sure they stay in place
those efforts to be really really
aggressive and see we get them waiting
and see if anyone steps out of line I'll
get sorted out quickly we can never be a
hundred percent certain but it's
generally thought that the oldest female
leads she's got the most experience in
avoiding predators so that's the reason
why she
to the front that's why the stallion
wants to try and make sure that his
harem isn't a less one come time that
they come into East hrus and of course
he wants to have as many babies as
possible
as there was a bit far at the moment for
the Lions to sort of spring up
immediately and start stalking also the
terrain isn't in their favor you can see
especially now that it's still light
very short open grass there and that
would be there would definitely be
spotted as they got up and started
walking towards where the zebra heading
Oh Dee Dee farming is wondering is there
tourists on the back of a vehicle with
it no Eddie that is our Ascari wild
Ranger when we operate after Park times
we have to have a park ranger with us
so the third person on the back of
Taylor's vehicle was Sammy who's one of
the Rangers and who comes out with us at
night so no visitors just cameraman and
news oh no it's Craig and Teller and
that Sammy the arranger for the evening
when these lines look like they're going
to hunker down for a bit
and he has upset black wings in the
distance Scotty you would like to know
will the zebra herd assist another zebra
that's being attacked depends on
situation a male or female zebra from
the same harem will attack something
small like a hyena or cheetah or even a
leopard and wild dogs sometimes that
attack are attacking a member of their
their their their herd but with lions
that they're white they'll they'll
generally move off as fast as possible
and I'm sure as it gets
oh what's that is that a water walking
this way now you see what I'm looking
fake so just to the right of the Lions
so zoom now a little bit more to the
right here we go about Center for him
now
what is that there oh no that's all it's
a secretary bird and she's getting
bombarded that's what all the commotions
from the lap wings are so of course if
they've got little chicks their
secretary bird is a predator and
although they normally eat snakes and
lizards and rodents a baby lap wing
would have go down quite the treat you
can see how upset all the birds are it
looks like I can't see it this distance
what the smaller birds are probably so
stick Euler's also very upset with their
presence in the area you can see how
that crown is up agitation flustered
from being attacked here comes the next
next load of bombardment - coming I
think she's out of the danger zone
obviously where the chicks all the eggs
are and the secretary bird has moved
beyond so they're not attacking her as
aggressively so and its head all the way
back to South Africa to find out what
Tristan is active lioness has gone
stationary for the time being she's just
having a little sit down we haven't
gotten too much further than where we
were just now she kind of moved along
lay down and they nose up again and now
that down for a little bit I don't think
she's gonna be down for too long you can
see she's still looking around and he's
quite awake she's staring into the
distance and checking what's going on
and she's really not that sleepy quite
wide eyed as you can see there
so I don't think she'll be down for too
much longer I'm pretty sure she's gonna
be up and moving and she's got a long
way to go from where I gather the income
a pride is there close to the simmer
Amelie arethusa cut line but quite far
to the west so she's got a long long
trick in order to find them I'm sure
she's hoping that they're going to come
East I spoke too soon it's now down to
sleep again but I'm sure she's good they
hoping they come East and then I
wouldn't be surprised if maybe a buffalo
is on the menu at some point hopefully
like I said that pride of lions in the
north chases those Buffalo south and
into the waiting jaws of the increment
pride here on Juma because that would
just be the perfect way for our evening
to play out of course the ink uma pride
and would probably only hunt that
Buffalo way off to drive but tomorrow
morning even it's fine there in Kumar
Prada can wait until the morning and as
we get going in the buffalo can come and
we can have a showdown between the two
of them in judging by the looks of the
pride they really could do with a nice
big meal it's amazing though how lions
can go from emaciated and thin and
looking a little bit on the sort of side
of skinny to completely fat and healthy
after one meal we saw the sticks pride
yesterday and how they were big barrels
after they water back and it would be
the exact same for the income as if we
had to get a buffalo carcass for them
they would be massive by the time they
finished it they would be really in
great condition again so muscular
structure is really good it's just that
she's a little bit on the skinny side
because of all this moving that she's
been doing up and down so I'm pretty
sure she will hope for a buffalo carcass
because it means that she can have a
good feed come and suckle the Cubs go
back feed again and keep that nutrient
level up for these little ones so that
they stay fat happy and healthy which is
what we want as well we want our Cubs to
be healthy and to survive and you know
she's in a period now it's the most
dangerous part for these Cubs the the
first three months is very difficult for
a lioness she's got to go back and forth
and she explains masses of energy trying
to look off to these little ones and
trying to keep up with a pride and keep
nutrient levels up and install supply
that to the Cubs and make sure that they
surviving well as well as choosing the
right places to leave them in order for
them to stay safe you
see now she's leaving those Cubs all on
her own she's gonna go and try get back
to the pride and those Cubs are gonna
have to fend for themselves for the next
24 hours or so until she comes back
hopefully she won't be 20 files they
generally should be coming back every
sort of 12 hours we see them moving
backward and forth but it could be 24
hours a full day until she gets back to
where they are and then you'll find a
situation where you know she's got to
provide nutrient-rich milk for them to
survive and who knows what moves through
here at that time they could be hyenas
that comes through leopard other lions
and so those Cubs are really at a
dangerous point in life the other
problem that she's got is that she's the
only lion is staining remember last year
in the increment pride end there was two
lionesses pretty close together that
then and then a third one about a month
later so it wasn't really too long until
the third one was and so those three
could help each other and share the
responsibility and they also moved
around as a unit which meant that
hunting wise they were able to bring
down small prey animals and also the
droughts halton that they could bring
down buffalo and that meant that the
Cubs grew quickly because these guys
were providing nutrition for them and
they were able to kind of stake when
close proximity which is a little bit
different to what we're seeing this year
od farming you wondering why she's the
only lioness with the Cubs well it's
quite simple is that the three lionesses
that we know have the Cubs currently so
those sub adults and they still
dependent on those lionesses so those
lionesses are not going to come into
Easter's probably for another I would
say six months to a year maybe even
longer until they'll come into an e
stress and start mating again so it's
gonna be a while if those all those Cubs
survive all those sub L survive so the
design isn't gonna be a while the only
other two lionesses is this one and
amber eyes amber eyes we don't know
we've never really seen her with a cub
there was that one mystery cub in the
middle of the year I think was in June
that no one's really sure what happened
or where it came from or what its
outcome was but that could theoretically
have been amber eise's cub and must have
been a mother's cover if we think of the
time frame because this lioness must
have been pregnant at the time and so
that cub unfortunately is no longer
there's no ways that that cub is alive
and it means
and Amber's really is the only other
female that could potentially have a
chance to have Cubs and she would have
had to have mated which means that she's
falling outside at the time that this
female is having Cubs so even if she's
mating now it's still gonna be three
months time until she gives birth to
hers and so it's a-you know they haven't
been quite in sync so that's why she's
the only lioness with the Cubs currently
or new Cubs there's no real there's no
real sort of other lionesses that can
potentially produce now and in the
timeframe while she's having her so I
mean amber eyes would be such a nice
thing if she did produce Cubs but as far
as we know she never has and it will be
really interesting if she ever will
because I suppose that little cub was
hers I mean it can't be anybody else's
if we just do the maths it has to be her
cub because this line is there's no way
she could have mated and fallen pregnant
and had these Cubs in that time frame we
fought too close to that time for her to
have mated again in that Club so it has
to have been amber izes cub and and
maybe she can produce cubs and in the
future we will see her bringing cubs up
and raising Cubs when we saw her
yesterday she did have signs that she'd
been mating but a few bite marks on the
back of the neck and so I wonder if
maybe she hasn't started mating again
and we'll see her falling pregnant it
would be nice if she did and we be also
nice for this female if she then deigned
in the next sort of six or to eight
weeks if she had fallen pregnant from
the mating and and was in this area and
helping this female arts because it's
interesting that a Myers and his female
must have had a very tight bond last
year because when the income of pride
spent so much time here on Juma and we
used to find empires and this female
often roaming around to give in random
places even the beginning of this year
used to see these two around tree hosta
moving around all over the place and so
they seem to have gotten on and have
formed a bond over the fact that they
didn't have Cubs and so it would really
I think hopeless female vampires was
around with her and I'm sure the two of
them together would really do very well
in raising Cubs should they want to so
it would be really nice if she did for
pregnant and have Cubs and
in this sort of time period and
obviously for the growth of the income
of pride the more females that have Cubs
the better but either way it's out of
five lionesses there four of them with
Cubs currently is really very good
there's a testament to the birmingham's
ability to defend the area our Larimer
is saying you wonder why Lions don't
bring food to a lioness with Cubs you
know wolves do it and the painted dogs
or wild dogs they also will do those
kind of things well the thing is about
it is because the lioness is it depends
at the moment the the rest of the
lionesses they trying to protect their
cubs that are at the carcass themselves
so coming back all the way here
expending the energy leaving their
caucus unprotected or bringing bits of
that carcass all the way here is
difficult to remember also that Lions
are hunting big animals they hand
something like a buffalo
there's no ways that's the in boomer
pride can drag a buffalo from some
amelie all the way to where we are now
that's over sort of seven eight
kilometers and a buffalo weighs almost
2,000 pounds so even if the entire pride
took turns I can guarantee you they
wouldn't even get halfway in a day so
it's gonna be that's the other side of
it is taking food like that is almost
impossible and then the third thing is
if you take food to a den you are taking
a scent to a den so you're taking the
smell of meat and rotting meat and that
means that that mean sort of predators
and scavengers are going to follow that
scent and come in and then it's going to
bring things like hyena lion leopard
into where the den site is for that
female and it's going to put those Cubs
at risk so rather than that they eat
they make sure that they consume meat
that then gets pushed into the milk the
milk nutrients then get transferred to
the Cubs the Cubs grow very fast during
that first little period and once they
reach that 3-4 months phase they then
starting to be taken to the carcasses so
the mother comes and fetches them and
then walks them all the way to the
carcasses and then they will stay and
spend time there and then they'll follow
the moms around so it's much better
system that way she can look after them
a lot better and they're not also being
at caucuses where things like hyenas can
arrive and they then endanger this way
she's bringing no scent she's not having
any vultures around she can suckle him
in peace and there's really little
that's going to follow her
you'll also find she's gonna use
different pathways to get you she's
never gonna walk exactly the same and
that means that the hyenas won't be able
to track her scent every single time so
she'll take maybe she'll go west this
time tomorrow she goes south the next
day she's north and so it makes it a lot
harder for the hyenas to pinpoint where
she's got coming and going from and
therefore the Cubs survive so here's all
method in their madness
remember also with ten animals like wild
dogs and and wolves there is generally
one member that is left permanently with
the Cubs or the pups or sa and they can
then sort of disorientate a predator and
need a predator away from that area
lions don't have that ability to do that
because they are needed with the hunting
and like I said they roam quite big
distances and they don't use a central
point for the den the den is fairly
mobile and gets moved all over the place
as opposed to what we see with things
like wolves and wild dogs where there's
a central bin and then the pack moves
around that area so just slightly
different with them and it works for
both species lions are fairly successful
we've seen that you know the numbers
within the sabi sands are doing okay
it's just that we've had a lot of
different males come through and that's
what's affected them in terms of den
sites and actual females keeping cubs
alive it's actually not been too bad the
sabi sands most of the females are
pretty good at what they do it's just
unfortunately the coalition males have
been such a swift turn over that that's
led to a decline in the population of
lions and the decline in all the prides
throughout the sabi sands really there's
not many prides that have actually grown
in the time that I've been here in fact
the only prize that have grown since
I've been here is the Hmong gained pride
the Hmong gained breakaway pride and the
salal as those are the only ones that
have actually in some way expanded every
other pride has actually reduced and as
no longer there's the same numbers as to
when I started here so it's an
interesting dynamic and like I say it's
because of the change in coalition males
that keep coming through
Lolita you're asking if lionesses from
the pride will come back for these Cubs
if this lioness dies in all likelihood
no and the reason why I say that is
because none of those females currently
have very small Cubs if there was a
female that had very small Cubs and it's
possible and and they have been sort of
applying cases where females have
adopted the offspring of sisters or
aunts or mothers or whatever the case of
may have been and we know the Charleston
female down the south she adopted her
sister's Cubs and raised them so they do
do it sometimes but in the case of the
Charlestown females she her Cubs got
killed and I think that mothering
instinct when her Cubs got killed plus
the mother of the other Cubs meant that
she took on Cubs because she was still
producing milk that that instinct to
mother was still there and that's why
she did it if it was a lioness that has
got older sub adults that she's stolen
too dependent on her she's not going to
now have the burden of trying to suckle
Cubs because she's not producing milk
remember she's got her own cubs to worry
about
and so these Cubs are still too young to
survive without milk they still need
milk up until they're around six seven
months old so they need to have a female
that's producing milk in order to save
them they're not gonna survive just on
meat at this age they need that milk and
they need all the antibodies and the the
all the bits that of nutrients that the
mom is passing on that's going to help
them fight infections get the digestive
tracts working properly and and all of
those kind of things that's all needed
before they're able to start consuming
meat full time and it means that you
know she's got it unfortunately in this
there's another lioness and as Cubs
fairly soon is producing milk these ones
would then be unfortunately left by
themselves and not looked after at all
right Arun Kumar female is out cold so I
think we're gonna carry on we're gonna
leave it be I was hoping that the Cubs
would be here and we know that brains
neo Smith and amaras but two lionesses
then it seems like they're on the hunt
so we're gonna try and find a spotted
creature of our own and while those
lionesses look for food well we're still
with the two girls from the sausage pad
they have not moved a muscle there she's
moved a muscle I think it's the biting
insects that have caused her to move
lots of biting flies and we had a hot
date today after the rain last night
which would have caused an absolute
exposed explosion of insect life and
speaking of that right next to us and
making art there are thousands of little
midges of course we're right near some
water as well so with water and rain and
Sun comes lots of course so those you
don't know what horrors are cause are
they sort of a South African ism sort of
a nickname for bugs I'm trying to think
well this why Healey they're called doot
Doo doos that is a swipey word for
insects or bugs Doo doos when we were
little kids we used to call them new
news
now notice as that tail flicks
occasionally out of the grass it's got a
very distinct black tuft ELISA is
wondering why is the tuft of a lion's
tail black well it's lots of different
reasons actually said but all of them to
do with that non of non-vocal old non
vocal communication as so and their will
to signal cubs are able to follow that
through thick grass and when they're
hunting the back black behind the ears
and the black tips of their tails are
used as ways to communicate now I was
talking about bags just look on here
Betty there look at that and I said that
the biting flies aren't and force after
the rain and fortunately for us there
are on the lines and not on us because I
think I'd be slapping myself silly
trying to get rid of that many flies on
me
there you go you can see she's getting a
little bit faster by them and that's one
of the reasons why quite a few different
prides in the Mara liked palm trees to
try get up into the the the breeze and
away from all the biting bugs oh very
pretty on the horizon fig a tipple
sketch it's gonna be silhouetted against
ortley and see I'm walking they're very
very pretty
giraffe walking a little bit to the left
they should go there we go
a little bit to the right there it is
weighted against that lovely orangey
pink suit of the western horizon now
come on keep walking for the pretty shot
don't stop for a snack yeah female Masai
giraffe I was a few there now I could
only see with my naked either the one
that was silhouetted and there's quite a
few snacking around that area difficult
to see what they're eating on from this
distance I'm afraid they're probably
seven or eight hundred metres away from
us
Paul is wondering do we wear any
specific type of bug spray while we're
on Drive
we don't Porter um bug spray is pretty
much ineffectual against most of the
really nasty biting insects occasionally
I might use some mosquito repellent but
very very seldom and not really here
here we are at lovely herd of elephants
as well having a late evening snack it's
amazing how much you can see if you're
sitting in one spot and you just
carefully check all around
that's exactly what I'm doing now having
a quick scan with my binoculars saying
if there's something we might have
missed it doesn't look like it just some
zebra topi and an Egyptian pair of
Egyptian geese you can hear that that's
a bubbling cocina starting to wake up as
I said we're right next to where lugger
drains are since the old Geppetto swamp
so we're probably going to hear lots of
frogs this evening you can see you know
a great spot to be if you're a frog and
the frogs are probably one of the only
things that are celebrating after all
the rain last night
therefore you found their fig yeah I
think algae I thought very good found a
frog tick tick tick taking of stream
frogs and it sounds like paddle frogs
and then you've got that lovely sort of
liquid jewel over the bubbling Cocina
and not so lovely where where where of
one of the toads not sure exactly which
sounds a little bit too soft to be
guttural raucous and of course they
could be all hosts of Toad species for
me to learn in East Africa our Lions are
still not moving at all a spiky head up
every now and then but looking like
they're about to charge off and go look
for something else
now quite often at this time of the day
it's not good to be a warthog and quite
a few warthogs sort of get snapped at
this time of the day because they're on
their way home and the home could be
amongst any of the mini termite mounds
that are around here and they can
stumble upon a lion that's fast asleep
but of course these big cats can wake up
in a split second
it's not even that oh here we go as I
said now let's have a look at the belly
oh not too hungry but definitely could
eat actually think that I didn't have a
good luck [ __ ] the fact that might be
carrying that weight quite far back
who knows maybe she's pregnant but I
think it's the flies that caused her to
just move and flop a few meters away the
spine is is practicings in with the
fly's incomplete I'm trying to
completely ignore them
no of course and they said there's quite
a lot of zebras and things around and
you can actually see the we're on the
edge of the ears from the biting flies
so that the animals have bitten so
prolifically that the hair starts to
fall out in certain spots where those
flies are biting I'm glad they're biting
her and not me
they can't be quite painful those little
biting flies
I said isn't not even a breath of wind
we're starting to get some lovely
birdsong coming through I can hear Rufus
nipped lark
I can hear yellow-throated Longclaw oh
we can hear black belly busted or as I
said that the wind is picked up and I
can't hear any more of the birds
well it's use like Tristan's being on
such a cat streak he's decided to go see
if he can find something else let's go
find out
ah so thanks very much for that sins Oh
because my comms are not working once
again our broken earpiece seems to be at
its finest if it's once again so it's
interesting though to see differences
between the lines and the Marr and the
ones yes it's watching some footage this
morning they look absolutely massive
some of them some of them look like
cubes as Lucy's walking through the
grass and it's been amazing to see how
different the dynamics are and how fluid
the movement is is during the migration
it's a lot more fluid than what we see
from our lines are lines tend to be very
stacked together so quite interesting
sort of differences that side and I'm
super jealous of Taylor this afternoon
already because she's got to see those
black rhinos and well obviously black
rhino here is the most rare and special
thing possible so we see very very very
very very very very few black rhinos in
the kruger national park system
unfortunately so and she is very
fortunate to have got to spend some time
with him this afternoon which is good
like I say I'm envious of her although
I'm pretty sure she's going to be
envious if we find her sana just now
because we know Taylor also loves her
spotted cats as well I believe she got
to see a leopard in the Mario the other
day which is fantastic and she's seen
all kinds of interesting things the
serval with the bullet with the hyena on
the wildebeest and the striped polecat
and lots of crazy things have gone miss
McCurdy's way over the last little bit
and I'm sure she's having an absolute
blast that side as well as and Jamie and
Brent and it's one of the more louder
groups of people together now Ellie
hoping to find shadow and her cub yeah I
know the guys check for her this morning
so the guys had a little look and they
checked in those areas around Mendoza
road and and in pilot planes Triple Aim
but unfortunately no sign of her at all
so I think she might still be in either
arethusa
or in Hoffman's somewhere in those areas
it's difficult though to know for sure
we know that she can be quite elusive so
no sign on our side though at the moment
and it would be nice to find her they
certainly would love to see shadow and
the cub again but I think well the one
that I want to see the most right now is
probably Sean Gilda that's the female
that I would like to see more than any
other Didache say last night that if we
don't see her and she's staying safe
then that's absolutely fine but I would
really like to see her and really like
to spend some time in
just see how she's doing it just to know
that she's okay and just one sighting
would be fine and then she can go back
to being elusive again now before I go
anywhere there is something that does
not belong here in the sabi sands and
certainly does not belong on the grounds
or in the bush and that is a plastic
packets and so I don't know how this has
gotten here but it is going to not be
picked up by us quickly and Iceman
purified ice is certainly not what we
want to see Archer like I said I'm not
quite sure how the Scott yeah but well
it's going to stay in the car from now
on and we make sure that it doesn't blow
away sins oh so if you can tuck it in
there somewhere so that it just stays
that would be pretty good as well
sometimes what happens is with the wind
I mean the the guys come to fetch the
rubbish because we're trucks are coming
in sometimes a little wind gusts and off
goes a bit of it or monkeys raids have
been or hyenas raid a bin and then these
plastic bags end up unfortunately
archers it's our prerogative just to
kind of pick them up and make sure that
we keep this as clean as possible and
litter free this is ultimately the
animals home not ours and so we should
not impose ourselves too much on them
I thought we were gonna have a lot more
of a sort of Sonya afternoon it seems as
though it was a lot more was clearing up
at lunchtime but it's now gotten all
overcast and dingy again and if we will
get a sunset I'm hoping that the clouds
do clear because if we do get a sunset
then we're gonna have a situation where
it's gonna be very pretty with all these
cards lighting up the different colors
and we're gonna get a really nice clear
kind of view of the Sun
are you're asking if the roads are made
randomly if they made by the Rangers
well our our the roads are made by the
basically the landowner and some of the
ecology guys that come together and they
try and work out where the best places
for roads are unfortunately in the back
in the day we didn't quite understand a
lot of the dynamics within the bush
environment and what it takes for roads
to be built and where they should be in
order to not cause environmental damage
and so some roads are not quite in the
right place but generally there's some
planning that goes into them and then
they are built by the ecology teams or
even the Rangers sometimes as well so it
is a planned thing these are not just by
mistake and not just tracks that are
made and these are all planned roads you
will see sometimes little two tracks
that go into places so it looks as
though vehicles are driven there that's
generally when we've had a big sighting
that's loss of a few days in a road
develops which is generally because
there's been multiple cars going in and
out and the grass gets squashed but as
soon as the rain comes that all
rejuvenates and spruces up again and up
comes the grass and everything looks of
all rights and wonderful I'm just trying
to adjust the blankets that I sit on
because the blankets that I sit on or
helping me I don't know I'd like to be a
little higher and the seat on windy and
rust here both of them I seem to have
lost a lot of this sponge and you kind
of sink into them and when I got out
there the blanket and quite go right and
so just adjust that quickly my apologies
for me bouncing around in my seat like a
hooligan the reason why I've come down
this road though is because I want to
quickly just check on our Wahlberg's
Eagle pair if they at the nest I did see
them on my way home this morning after
drive they were sitting in the nest and
they well but not in the nest they were
just next to it and it was the pale form
individual that was there the dark form
one was flying above but the pale form
one was actually then that's the one
that seems to be on the nest a lot more
we saw it yesterday on the nest and so
hopefully in this kind of weather being
a little bit sort of dingy and gray and
dull maybe one of them will be somewhere
where the nest is and hopefully we can
get a view of them they are beautiful
birds particularly pale from one sheet
she or he depending which one it is very
difficult to 6 or Bugsy there's no
difference between male and female and
so it would be really nice in fact both
of them are here I can see them already
I'm just gonna try go a little bit
forward so we get a better view of them
hopefully they won't fly away stay there
guys
and they unfortunately gonna be a little
bit silhouetted because of where they
sitting and the white sky that we've got
a gray white sky that we've got today
but there they are sitting on top of the
tree itself although they look like both
pale form individuals where am I wrong
they do look both pale are they both
pale certainly looks that way
as our dark form male been chased or
dark form female been traded for a pale
form individual looks like it looks like
the plot is thickened that's interesting
it's definitely too pale form
individuals that are busy grooming each
other and it's too early in the season
to have a young one already we know that
these guys have only just arrived so
it's can't be the chick but that is
really quite strange because this
morning there was the dark form and the
pale form together but you can clearly
see there that is too pale form
individuals that are grooming each other
and I wonder if maybe the dark for male
has been ousted which would be very
unusual generally Eagles pair for life
so really quite strange I'm not sure why
the dark form male would relinquish this
area or even there would be territorial
baths between them that's very strange
noise he said it's the first time I've
seen it was the Wahlberg's Eagles
because generally all the nests that we
have in these areas are the same pace
every year you come and you see the same
groupings I mean obviously it's quite
difficult to tell individuals apart but
you know the combinations are normally
you can tell because they have these
different color forms and can normally
tell who's who by just looking like
those kind of forms and where they are
and
like I said we know for sure that there
was a dark formed one with this light
formed one yesterday in the morning and
in afternoon and this morning so very
confused as to why those two are
together I hope something bad didn't
happen to our dark form well bears
that's not good well I suppose too pale
form ones are beautiful but I would have
liked it to stay the same and to have
the same pay as we always do but
interesting dynamic I'm gonna have to do
a bit of research on this I wonder if
Wahlberg's Eagles do you fight for pays
and we'll try go after each other so
makes I cannot hear you at all I'm
getting is every half a word with every
three four seconds which is not our deal
so we're gonna try and see if we can
fiddle with these comms and try and get
this right because otherwise I can't
answer any of the questions that you're
all asking which is not ideal makes can
we try again maybe we can do a little
Russian are you saying a triangle love
story there we go I can copy Megan now
it seems like it's a dark the dark for
males games more females going to be
very impressed with this triangular love
story it's given that it's not here but
very strange like I say I'll have to do
a bit more research it's the first time
I've seen the situation where there's
been a individual user ping another and
taking over and list this is a different
pair and they've taken this nice for
themselves and the dark Foreman and pale
one that we normally see has moved to a
different section that potentially could
happen maybe pairs Fortin we've now just
got a new pair in this area but very
strange indeed and I'm gonna like I said
I have to do a lot more research on this
and see if there's any documented
findings on Wahlberg's and whether it's
pairs that fight or whether it's
individuals within the ranks that will
chase one another art and form a new
pair but it's unusual to say the least
Rebeca they only mate once in a year so
they mates now and then they have the
young one and the young one then
obviously develops develops and Ellen
leaves here at the end of summer and
then flies northwards but they only
breed once a year and at the end of the
day birds of prey they Lodge which means
that they've got to incubates eggs for a
while and then the birds gotta learn how
to fly and that takes a bit of time we
know with vultures it's pretty much
almost a year and a half I mean just
over half a year for them to kind of get
them out the nest and so it's the same
thing with the Wahlberg's Eagles it
takes about 3-4 months for those birds
to get up and moving and flying and
being able to look after themselves and
so it's only one chick in the summer
months and then they don't breed when
they go to the northern hemisphere they
just breed down here in South Africa
that's very odd nice to see them though
they are beautiful birds like I say the
pale form Wahlberg's are incredibly
pretty so nice to see them and I'll try
to get a little bit closer so we can get
a bit of a closer view and see if we can
get some sort of pattern on them that we
can recognize them in the future and
whether or not they individuals that
will stay here and maybe some of you
that are very clever and can see some
sort of pattern or recognize some sort
of markings on the feathers can work out
whether it's one of the birds we saw
yesterday or it's a different pairing of
birds it's definitely not the lights now
that I'm closer they most certainly are
pale form both of them it all fluffed up
obviously because it's cold and I was
saying that it's not good conditions for
flying and that's why you'll find both
of them are down at the moment and just
resting on the tree and look at the size
of those talons on their feet and long
long long long long rectangular tails
that will help them to be able to
stabilize in flight because remember
these birds hunt other birds they birds
that hunt on the wing really and so long
tails need to stall them be agile it's
much like a cheetah has a very long tail
and helps just to be able to turn on a
dime and be agile as they move around
and so that's why you see such a long
tail and these
beautiful hmm another mystery that
jhummer if I'm not 100% sure why these
two are here
interesting that three the way try get
round and see something quickly because
where they sitting is off the nest a
little bit that's now I've got no comms
again there we go I can just share Megan
every second word which is getting worse
unfortunate is not good right so we can
quickly go across to Taylor because I've
missed my link completely so let's go to
her we're gonna stay this side in the
Triangle we just need to figure out
whereabouts the world to be crossed
Khan remember friend said their crops
on the eastern side of the bridge versus
the side of the bridge we do have a
quick repair on hope you were able to
find ourselves upon a vantage point of
some sorts and then use our binoculars
and haven't seen any lines and plenty
elephants around although
the liens haven't seemed to have
acquired the taste for elephants
wildebeest several walk behind our chair
and that's very specifically warthog now
with their most of the animals moving
out of the triangle they've got to go
back to catching pigs
you're just gonna keep looking as I keep
reaching up on these Ron Rises I'm
starting to see the trees you must be
getting closer and closer to the morrow
of that
quite exciting our check we can find
some herds of wildebeest
I haven't read he's been much time
massage brain Tesla this is one of his
favorite areas hopefully it'll become my
favorite area - speaking of Brent let's
go back to him and see what he stands
off the rest of the evening
well as you can see our lines have
decided it's much better to nap
then do anything else for the moment at
least now you got to remember that
patience is the most important thing
when you're out in the bush and because
you never know what's going to happen
next and suspecting Warthog might come
careering in unknown pride of lions
might come careering in and cause
absolute havoc so sometimes we have to
play the patience game and sit and wait
for those incredible sightings and not
much else has changed and we've actually
lost that our elephants that were near
us they've moved off the giraffe have
disappeared the only thing left is the
egyptian geese that are grazing
comfortably out on that lovely short
green grass where the little ziege
empties out into the swamp all
stretching and I think we're going to
lose them shortly as well as they fly
off to find somewhere to roost now the
one thing a lot of people don't realize
that an Egyptian goose is not in fact a
goose at all it is a form of shield duck
it is actually what they are but there
are grazers so they eat grass so you
will find them munching along on any
lovely short green grass now I've seen
something quite amazing and I've only
ever seen it once and it was here a few
weeks ago or probably maybe in a few
months ago now and and that was an
Egyptian goose eating the stomach
contents of ávila bees that have been
killed by lions and they're not quite a
fresh kill
so they're the the geese were eating
that undigested grass that was left
behind
now being the vast open grass and that
it is these beasts might not even have
files to find somewhere to roost they
might just stay right where they are
Alana is 14 years old would like to know
have we seen any odd [ __ ] in the Mara oh
I've seen about four or five and we
actually did a Facebook live once on
that Lions hunting art [ __ ] and that was
quite special that's definitely not
something you get to see every day
Lions hunting art [ __ ] and that was
actually just over the horizon over
there and it was the Egyptian goose
pride and nearly nearly got that I'd
[ __ ] he managed to get down the hole and
then while the young male was trying to
dig him out and the art [ __ ] was digging
at a much faster rate and distance and
into the male's face it was quite funny
but yes no we've seen quite a few art
[ __ ] seen on both sides of the river in
fact I've also seen the other art that
lives gentleman's is the art wolf so one
of those way down south near the
Tanzanian border seen a striped polecat
or Cirillo which is a African form of
skunk I've seen a edge hogs what else
have we seen lots of funny little things
at night
caracals serval seen both sides drive
and black-backed jackal bat-eared Fox
white el Mongoose water mongoose I've
seen quite a lot of the the smaller
nocturnal critters and Janet's Bush
babies the like these lions are truly
truly flat as I said they're reasonably
well fed not too skinny and I was hoping
that all those ever around which have
now gone might prompt them to do
something so we might take a little
wonder just now and then come back here
a little later but it really doesn't
look like these guys are going anywhere
too soon
winds starting to pick up but
fortunately not bring any rain towards
us just yet
well we've got a new viewer who named
Dakota who is 15 years old a big welcome
to you Dakota lovely to have you on the
vehicle with us and Dakota wants to know
how do we get so close to the Lions
well Dakota when were in a vehicle the
Lions don't know that there are people
here that do not have an evolutionary
instinctive response to the vehicle so
the vehicles only been around for just
over a hundred years so if you drive
carefully and considerately and it
doesn't smell like anything nice to eat
it's too big really and they pump just
ignore you after time but it does take
time to obituary them to vehicles but if
I were to get out of the car and start
walking we would definitely get a
reaction now it is still light so they
would probably run away so lions are
actually quite scared of people during
the daytime hours but at night they
become a different animal and they are
the dominant nocturnal predator and we
are the dominant diurnal predator so
they'll eat us at night but normally
unless you corner or put pressure on
Cubs or an injured lion
during the day they will try and move
away from you on foot that's why we can
get very close to to them in vehicles
because they don't recognize a vehicle
and they recognize the human shape as
the dominant daytime predator
now something we've got quite used to
here is ominous skies they seem to be
around every evening since I've been
back from leave but it sounds like
Justin has got an ominous sky of his own
all the way back in South Africa not
really been T it's not too bad like I
said this morning it was ominous and
this morning there was big dark clouds
and it really did look like we were
going to get some rain at some point and
we got a few droplets here and there but
nothing too major so it wasn't too bad
this morning but I'm it imagine now it's
starting to sip right Alton and I think
that's the end of the rain for us the
more I look up the less likely it looks
that we going to get any more rain and
the fact of the winds dropping and
there's really no solid bank that's
being gusted in by the wind means that I
think we're done for the day
unfortunately remember we'd love to have
more rain we need it I'm looking very
carefully because this is the area where
I had those tracks for that's young male
lipid that was moving and I had lots of
alarm calls in this section so I'm just
checking very carefully as I'm going in
case little tumba is maybe somewhere in
this general vicinity as well and just
hiding out we know he likes it in this
area so just having a look around
checking some of the termite mounds and
some of the trees and he doesn't seem to
be a cat that spends much time in the
trees in fact I don't think I've ever
seen him in a tree have I no I didn't
think so
didn't think I've seen him in trees but
I've seen him on lots of termite mounds
and in lots of river beds so he seems to
favor this Milwaukee system maybe as a
young individual it's just more
comfortable for him to be down there
interesting that I haven't seen him in a
tree before him in a tree before it's
actually quite crazy when I think about
it given how many sightings I've had of
him I would have thought that at some
point I would have had him up a tree but
so far no
what have I no I don't think so I'm
trying to Rack my brains but I honestly
don't think I've ever seen him up in a
tree but I think we are going to get a
nice sunset it looks as though the
clouds are breaking on the western side
and a little bit of color starting to
creep in that side so hopefully we will
get a good sunset I'm just making my way
towards twin dams as I go along and like
I said looking for Humber as we go but
we our main goal is to get back to me I
had a sauna this morning and see if he's
sitting in the same place I would
imagine he is I don't think he's gonna
have gone too far he's an individual
that once he's at twin dance generally
spends the afternoon fairly relaxed and
sleepy and doesn't actually move around
too much
I would guess he's going to be there
whether or not he is is well we're going
to be all revealed in the next two
minutes
so George you wondering what happened
with sunburn husana the other night when
they faced often what the outcome was
well George it seems both of them just
splits amicably where we lost him fairly
soon after the drive finish so I was
looking and I was trying and
unfortunately they were instant a really
dense thicket and there was just no way
to keep up with him given how fast they
started moving they were kind of
trotting at him after each other and so
I lost them with that regard but they
seemed fine both have been seen since
I've seen both of them neither one is
support sporting a scar a scrape a
scratch any sort of limp so I think what
happened was tumbler ran into thickets
husana lost him him completely and the
two of them then just kind of splits
amicably and that was the end of this
there was no major threats in it and
given that they neither one is
territorial yet I don't think they're
going to go after each other right we
are you little Hosanna
I don't see him anywhere though it's not
where we left him this morning so he's
not here where we left him he was just
on the left hand side when we left him
this morning he's trying to check for
him we have you gone he's lying on the
other side of the damn wall
who is he in front here somewhere
interesting we're going to have to
scratch around and check for him but I
don't see him anywhere oh there is this
sitting right in front of us if he was a
snake as they say he would have bitten
me so I'll just try and get down a
little bit but he is fast fast fast fast
fast fast fast asleep at the moment he's
in his usual spot that he seems to favor
which is just along the edge of the
banks here and on this wall itself I
don't know why he likes it so much there
but he seems as though this is where he
wants to spend his time it was exactly
the same place a few weeks ago or a few
days ago he was lying really in the same
way just on the edge and and you can see
he's still very relaxed how we've missed
him from far away I have no idea it just
shows you their camouflage because I was
looking at the damn wall and I didn't
see him until we got a little bit closer
and that's where were you sitting just
resting and he looks fast asleep at the
moment but you can see no scratches on
him anyway on the ramp area so seems as
a human tumbler just had a little
faceoff investigating each other a few
snarls and hisses and growls and to say
you're not my brother you're not my
relative and I'm going to move on and
off I go it was such an interesting
interaction though between the two of
them because tumba or seem to just
really not care at all he kind of sought
time by approaching and I mean saw us on
approaching and just carried on drinking
and then once a sauna got really close
then he started to spread display a bit
submissively and kind of lie on his side
and growl and hiss and show his teeth
but otherwise they weren't too
aggressive to one another it was a bit
of sniffing going on and then they kind
of chased each other around so I think
they still in that young phase where
they're not quite sure how to handle
those interactions when they see one
another and when things get a little bit
sort of hairy and they just do what they
used to doing which is chuffing and
being submissive and keeping themselves
alive that way so it will all change
though once they start scent marking and
once they start to go into that adult
phase and testosterone is flooding then
you'll find that they'll be far more
aggressive to any opponent that they
face it might not be each other but they
will end up having to face off with some
male somewhere and you'll find that
interaction will be a lot more
aggressive and a lot more teeth and
claws and all kinds of other things as
they try and defend a territory or gain
the territory first before they
defending anything some males have it
easy some are like quarantine where he
just bosses his way in doesn't have to
really fight with anybody he just calls
and st. marks and there he is in
position and has himself a territory
others have to fight for it and earn the
right to be territorial and that takes a
bit of time and effort and so it's
interesting just how the differences
work between some of them and so
hopefully for a sauna and Tom bear I
really hope either one of them that they
get a nice territory and they don't
actually have to worry about fighting
too much and they can get nice and
settled and get big before they then
actually start competing with other
males that's what I hope Chacma you say
such a beautiful cats wasana is
beautiful
he's looking ever-ever prettier I think
he's starting to lose the cub look but
he's starting to gain that sort of
steamy male look that they get the more
serious look but he's got a nice colored
coat I always liked her sanas coat it's
a yellowy color and as long as gold is
what you see on tumblr tom attempts to
have a darker gold color than what
Hassan and does but I like the color of
his coats and he's got these eyes that
are becoming more vibrant
by day by day and they really enjoy
watching and lately he's been endearing
himself a lot more to all of us by the
way that he's played around and messed
around and done his thing he's been very
entertaining to watch that's for sure I
remember him the other day with the
stick that he had in his mouth and he
was playing the stick and biting it and
so he is a very cool cat and like I say
whoever ends up hopefully it is in this
area but if it's not somebody's going to
inherit a very very special little chief
in their area and hopefully he'll become
the big chief somewhere somewhere close
by and if not here so that we can
monitor him and know where he goes and
what he gets up to because I thought the
worst thing about having young males is
that kind of invest all this time and
you get so emotionally attached to them
and then they shift off and especially
when they go into places like Kruger and
the sightings and the updates on them
become so slim and and few and far
between that it's most frustrating in a
way because you want to know how they're
doing and want to know how they're
progressing and so it's nice when they
end up inside a sabi sands system or a
timber Vaati system where there's a lot
of the commercial lodges that have
constant updates on them it really makes
it a lot better and a lot easier for us
to kind of know okay well they're doing
all right wherever they are and I think
that's the hardest part we know miss you
and do nourish of amber Lana all of
those have just burst into Kruger and
that the sort of updates on them are
very few and far between there's one
every now and then but it's not exactly
commonplace to see them it's not like
now with asana that we see him probably
every sort of have some sort of update
on him every day if we're not seeing him
we know exactly where he is or somebody
else is seeing him on another property
so we can work out exactly what's going
on but look at the size of that massive
front paw it's getting bigger and that
head as well starting to get a little
bit of a dewlap for me you can see his
skin is starting to hang a little bit
from the chin so he is growing and
slowly but surely becoming the male that
he needs to be and so while we watch her
sana let's go back to Brent with his
lionesses see what they're up to
we didn't go for a bumble because there
was some zebra distress calls in the
distance and the lion heads popped up
like they were going to move but
unfortunately it was very very
short-lived before those heads that went
straight down again gosh I'm tired
Kitty's probably had a few unsuccessful
hunts and sleeping off the tour at a
time they might have might have been
having not being able to catch anything
so I think we are going to leave them
nap and go on a little bumble and come
back to them a little bit later
I have one cloud over us that it was
that one it also rained all over us not
really too hard but enough to start
start me worrying slightly because it
sort of came out of no and that happens
quite often in the dark so you're
sitting there with lions the vehicles
open everything's wonderful and then you
have this on your roof and you go I
can't see any stars this is the problem
and then you get to come to me then you
have to rush to pull the tent down and
that generally means you've got to drive
away from the Lions of course we don't
want to be running around putting our
tents down next to the Lions and
sometimes can be quite comedic
you think of it Chilean shook her over
my legs
now as most of you that know I like my
Birds quite a lot and Russian years
wondering how different is the birding
during the different seasons well Russia
I suppose I haven't spent a full year
yet I can't tell you for sure but in the
summer season I'm looking forward to
seeing some of the migrants around but I
would say a lot of the Mara bird species
are resident and and that's due to the
weather yeah lots of lots of water all
year round so it is it is quite quite
quite nice oh there's a Telford
say hello quickly
I offered very good in yourself any
liens apart from the ones they're under
a young gamez on the other side okay
okay
maybe tomorrow just wine it was over
here oh that's on runner Ridge very
beautiful yes so Alfred's been watching
and he said he saw Jamie with the
Cheetahs this morning okay well good
luck I'm gonna go see if I can find the
rest of the pride there's only two
females here so I'm sure the other ones
up here somewhere I know tonight I'll
only stay out till maybe 8 o'clock 9
o'clock but other cars that pulling that
time and she'll be out to midnight one
o'clock
sometime there thank you very much
okay
okay well we're gonna see if we can find
the rest of the sausage tree pride or
maybe we'll get lucky with that female
gesture while we do that let's go to
Tristan who's looking at four little
things about twin dams I am looking at
little things at twin dam so we've got a
little water boatmen and you can see why
it's called a boatsman because of that
oval-shaped body with those two oars
basically they come out and help it swim
around underneath the water and it's not
every day we get to see them so super
cool watching them shoot about and swim
around and go crazy means the odd little
fish around as well there's another
water boatman going that way you can see
there's a big elephant ball of dung so
you can work out just how big our water
boatmen are they are tiny in comparison
to the elephant dung now they were one
or two fish around swimming in the
background I can't see them now they
seem to have moved off and there was a
dragonfly Lobby that also was there but
I don't know where that's gone but it
just gives you an idea of how small
there's another water boatman there you
can see it's always quite clearly very
cool little bit darker that one so nice
to see and it's not something we get to
see very often at all while Hassan is
sleeping since I've spotted all of these
different insects moving around in the
shallows of twin dams and it really is
very cool to see and mist all of these
insects and varying other small
invertebrates that are around water and
I wonder if they're not feeding off the
vegetation inside the hip inside the
elephant dung so you can see they're all
latching onto you see varying others
they also probably be using it a little
bit for safety because it'll be a place
where they are able to go down and fish
can't get them they looks like a fish at
the back is that a fish
looks like a little fish that's darting
forward so it doesn't look like the
boatman that's one that looks like a
small type of fish that is swimming what
kind of fish it is I'm not quite sure
there's probably little barbs is what
they are three spot barb is what we get
in this area George you're asking if we
can eat the fish in the lakes at Juma
George no these fish would be far too
small these fish are
tiny tiny tiny like I say that's a ball
of elephant dung to give you an idea of
just how small those fish are they are
minut so they wouldn't even be a snack
and no I don't know anything the water
here so sort of stagnant sometimes I'm
not sure I'd want to try one well though
I suppose it's as if we cook them
properly you could they are bream
species that we do get you that can be
eaten and catfish species that we call a
bobble and those will get eaten from
time to time and are okay but I'm not
sure I would be hugely into eating fish
out of some of these given what I've
seen go on in these water holes from the
elephant's defecating and urinating and
buffalo and all kinds of other things
that go on inside yeah but amazing to
watch isn't it it's not something we get
to really see very often at all so
they're not fish they are boatsman even
those lighter colored ones I thought
they were fish but they're not they're
an insect that is moving around it's
quite difficult to see because obviously
it's through some murky water and a
little those are not very dark like that
other boat when we saw just now and so
they tough to see I thought like I say
that they fish but they they're not
they're insects and then I'm moving
around in the water but well spotted
sensor that is super cool Bri Bri you
say so much activity there is so much
husana was completely sleepy and but
he's waking up now starting to groom
himself he's been yawning a little bit
so I think he's had a day of rest and I
wouldn't be surprised we're gonna start
getting going now hopefully it's not
gonna be suffered so I'm hoping he's
gonna start heading north wouldn't be I
wouldn't mind going on a hunting
expedition with husana it would be
really nice to see him hunting again and
you can see there's a bit of sunlight
now coming out I mean look at how
beautiful his colors look in that
sunlight he's getting that little bit of
color coming through and bit of grooming
going on and this is very typical of a
cat that's prepping to me so they groom
they get rid of any parasites that have
gotten onto them in whose fur that is
developed through the day get their
coats in good condition and see he's
cleaning between his toes there and
making sure that they're all prepped and
ready for the evenings moving around and
making sure that his feet are in good
condition like a little pedicure that
he's going through right now and making
sure that he looks
and is healthy so this is a typical sign
before cats get going and like I say
yawning coupled with this generally
indicates that we're gonna see some sort
of movement in the near future so
hopefully like I say it's north and not
south I really don't want him to go down
into little Gary because that will put a
bit of a ruin or dampener on my plans
this afternoon I was hoping that we'd
get here now and husana would start
waking up maybe have a little drink and
then from there start moving up the
moola wotty and maybe go on a little
hunting expedition lots of Yala's and
push back in impalas and Steinbach and
dykey in the actual mono artie on my way
down so hoping that he'll head that way
and do a little bit of hunting there but
isn't he beautiful very dexterous too as
well by the way that he's able to groom
almost on his own back which is pretty
amazing so nice to see the way he does
things really is very pretty lipid sauna
but I was also amazed about it's just
the size between
oh they went to darvid of almost landed
right in front of him you can see kind
of turned his head a little bit
so the dove is just on the left hand
side they saw me I can't see where it's
gone now since I think it's flown a
little bit past but you saw a dove
coming in and his eyes lit up for a
second and then decided no I'm not going
to have any of that and then just to
carry on grooming his brother his older
brother Siobhan Bella and that's how he
got his name is by catching a emerald
spotted wood dove because that's what
Siobhan B'Elanna means so that's where
you guys is doing exactly this was busy
grooming and then her dove flew past and
he just grabbed it out of nowhere but
how beautiful is the reflection in that
greenish colored water very very pretty
well done sensor this light is just
getting better it's almost starting to
full turn become a soft yellowy light
you often get the soft terrain you get
this most wonderful light developing in
the afternoons and it was exactly what I
was hoping for so I'm sure Hassan is
going to put on a wonderful show as he
sits there and enjoys the last of the
afternoon sunshine
now you can see is now moved on from the
front legs to the back legs and is doing
the exact same thing just grooming the
toes maybe a bit of sand in between
there keeping everything in check and we
will stay with him in monitor whether he
gets up and moves but from one spotted
cats in the sunset to another let's go
across the tail and a beautiful cheetah
whoa we made it finally we found
wildebeest we have also found with this
beautiful spotted cat whom I want to see
is if it is a male or a female you look
very much like a girl I did not see any
of the bits that make you a man but
we'll have a quick look and he just keep
up with her so I have a story to tell
you I met with one of the wardens and he
actually gave me the info on this
cheetah how kind of him he said that he
watched it chase after Impala and grab
an Impala lamb and then unfortunately
moves it to the hyenas which is sad for
the cheetah but it works out well for us
because it means someone's hungry
except we want this cat that's not it's
not drivers in Jenny halls we want this
cat to of course stay on the left-hand
side we don't want it to come to the
right because we cantle thrown on the
right-hand side so I'm gonna give her a
bit of space and this paint a wildebeest
around there's also loads of what else
is then some in parlour some zebra I'm
just scanning some trophy
yeah
what we will have to do though at some
point before this gets too exciting is
very quickly predict infrared lights on
but I just wanted to show you all this
beautiful cat it's so nice to see Neil
so just con quadruple check that it is
not a boy
look like it very lean though could do
with a meal
don't you think and let's see what's
going to happen where are you going to
go who you're gonna go for now she
better be careful go that you're going
that way though because I did see some
lions in me an area where we can't offer
open they're so far off the road and
unfortunately it's no good for us
especially when it gets dark you know
during the day it's different but we
lose light and our infrared lights can
only go so far Oh built for speed
I mean have you ever seen anything as
fantastic as a cheetah I think I'd
choose a cheetah over a sports car and I
think it fits a job - never seen a
sports car catch an Impala but hopefully
we'll see this cheetah catch one this is
very cool night I don't know what
cheetahs roam around this area I've
never been here before this is my first
time so we'll have to learn together
we're basically what are we we are East
ish of porin gate gate but still in the
Triangle so I don't know what cats like
to hang around here at all
hmm let's see Craig let's follow her but
I think I said we're gonna lose light
fast and before it gets too exciting
before she does go and chase something
we will have to put those infrared
lights on otherwise you are not going to
see anything we're going to miss the
hunt it became a racing yeah
I'm telling you still there
now brave are you wondering how much a
teacher ways she shouldn't spare me so
underweight because of well she hasn't
had a meal Oh though you might not how
much she weighs huh how much the tale
ways well that tales just about the
length of her body
I wouldn't know I'm should stop but a
cartilage muscle I'm gonna be much fat
there I don't know if it'll weigh too
much at all maybe less than a kilogram
but who knows I'm quite happy not ever
knowing how much it cheated tail weighs
just because I can only imagine one way
that you'd Wed and that would be a
cheetah with outer tails and it's let's
not even worry about how much shaking
way it's keep it on is it a good she
can't see very well
Craig can we zoom right wing is good
right in there see I can't you know I
said I'm fairly confident that it is a
female but watch it surprise me
she's very tall I suppose I'm so used to
seeing so many leopards Asuna but that a
a cheetah it will in in statures
obviously a lot more slender but the
cheetah different be taller than those
methods it was so lovely we didn't find
the leopard that it was also apparently
an effort sighting we had a little look
but there's the possibility though no
because there are quite shy aren't you
they're not like the sabi sand lipids
that possibly adduct off into one of the
drainage lines
now shouldn't L I don't know if you
heard me but reenacts right infrared
light song because she's obviously on
the move so she might be looking for
something to eat what on earth are you I
can see that tiny little bird on the
ground I have no idea what that is
someone take a screenshot please and
share it with me because I'd like to try
and figure out what it is I don't think
it's a mannequin no it's running
Pazhani on the ground that runs like a
ground dwelling bird never seen that
before
but I shall figure out what it is if you
take screenshots remember hashtags fire
it up and then I can identify it for you
later I'm gonna be out for most of the
night so I'll be able to do that
I'm telling you still there
wonderful right I'm gonna send you back
to Tristan and wasana but don't worry we
won't be gone for too long we're just
going to add our infrared lights
now Sanne is having a game with a
fruitful Franklin that keeps running
back and forth towards him he's now
lying flat pretending like he's not
interested in the Franklin is running
for its life but just now the Franklin
was actually coming straight towards him
there you go you can seize popped his
head up now because the Franklin has run
away but the Franklin was walking
straight towards him any kind of a hunch
Don and was trying to pretend like he
was not interested but I think he's
quite upset that if the Franklin has
gone all the way over that side but look
at how majestic he looks on the edge of
this water he's really turning into a
beautiful individual he's watching the
Franklin's on the other side of the dam
you can hear the Franklin's are chasing
each other around
larysa you're asking if cheetah lions
and leopard males and females reach
maturity at the same age or does it
differ between the sexes well it's it's
not that they reach maturity at
different ages is that the opportunities
to mate come at different ages so a male
lion male leopard even a male cheetah to
a degree they have to get stronger and
big enough to be able to compete with
other males and that normally takes a
little bit longer then when they're
actually sexually mature and able to
mate if you look at something like a
female leopard she's really starting to
mate a two and a half years old even
lionesses turn off three years old they
can start mating and they'll normally
conceive their first Cubs around four
years or three and a half four is
sometimes a little bit earlier if they
lucky but males generally don't come
right with mating until they're around
four to seven years depending on on the
individuals there are anomalies
obviously outliers on on that scale but
generally the males only are able to
mate at a much later stage but look how
serious he looks isn't he magnificent
Masana you are looking beautiful my way
he's very very well fairly he's healthy
he's definitely growing by the day
starting to get a very wide round face
thick neck and the male leopard in him
is starting to come out and blossom and
he's in his teenage years now so you
know he's gonna start going towards that
two-year mark and then once he starts to
get to three four then that's when he's
gonna really put on quite a bit of size
and then when he gets dominant and that
testosterone flash happens that's when
you'll do that last bulking up and then
become massive so hopefully he's gonna
be an impressive male and I'm pretty
sure he will be in wherever he ends up
but he is looking as regal as one could
ever want to see from a leopard he's
sitting beautifully for us at the moment
sitting almost looks as though he's kind
of surveying his landscape from his
throne which is twin dams wall and seems
to have become his place he loves
spending time here and watching what
goes on is varying different types of
birds and animals and all kinds of
things that come down to the section and
drinking so it's the perfect place for
to spend their time and isn't that
beautiful I think so I think there's not
very many things in this world that can
drive a a beautiful male lipid when it's
sitting head up like that legs crossed
on the edge of a waterhole it's a
magnificent scene we even got a bit of
card drama to our afternoon so you can
see that's kind of seen that we are
looking at at the moment and it really
is a beautiful one but you can see now I
saying it's difficult to spot him you
can see me camouflage when he's up
against that wall you'd think that
yellowy color would really Blair stand
out but as you can see from that it
doesn't the spots actually blend into
this mottled wall effect and he can
blend in very very well beautiful
carsten from denmark you asked me if any
of the big cats have the falling or
landing on their feet part that domestic
cats have yes leopards when they fall
out of tree I'm yet to see a leopard
land funny they always generally land on
their feet even when they fall and lion
stood to be they don't really fall
graciously but they will land on their
back legs or their front legs or a all
four of them but they generally don't
land on their backs ever they kind of
twist themselves in the air and land on
their feet so it is the same with
domestic cats as our lipids they do do
an alliance they do do the same thing
cheetah I've never seen a cheetah fall
out of a tree so I wouldn't know but
leopards I've seen fall out many times
and they generally do land on their feet
quite well unless of course you're
Anderson male and you're dragging a
carcass up a tree and then you basically
fall with the carcass that throws you
off balance and you don't bend land on
your feet at all you end up landing on
your back and side how he didn't injure
himself for those of you that don't know
what I'm talking about ants and mail was
videoed once taking an Impala up into a
tree and he then fell for some reason he
fell out with the Impala and landed in a
heap at the bottom of the tree so that
wasn't ideal and not very elegant but
it's very seldom where we see things
like that happening I'm just watching
the water
you're watching the Terrapins maybe he's
watching little water boatmen that we've
been seeing flocking past and swimming
past and he's intrigued by all of that
it's just a wonderful wonderful sight to
see him like this
he's almost looking as though to say
well the animals that come and drink at
this time of the day it's not a [ __ ] a
hot day so maybe the animals are not
coming down and he's going to have to be
patient and wait a lot longer for
anything to move into this area so I'm
just looking behind me to see if there
is any impalas or anything drifting but
nothing nothing nothing for him at just
yet
but it only is gonna be done for too
much longer I really do believe that he
is going to meet he's gonna yawn laughs
and I really believe that he is going to
start getting up and going short yet
maybe come down for a bit of a drink and
then he's going to start going now Hasan
is sitting patiently waiting looking
around and he really doesn't seem to
care too much about any of the other
animals that we get in this area but one
animal that will be worried about
running into other spotted predators act
we had the swing is the Cheetahs and I
believe Taylor's cheetahs are having a
tough time look who's sitting low on the
mound as a term and not as a honor to my
mind as the hyena came charging past him
she's not having much luck in coming
back again the song you know definitely
knows that the Cheetahs here now there
have been a couple of them calling about
I suspect there might be a danger
Barker's a sort of a couple of heads
popping up from the ground but in a non
off-roading section maybe this is the
one that stole her meal earlier it's
come in the direction that she was in
but it is heading off to the whooping
sounds that we heard just a moment ago
to obviously the rest of the clan there
you go don't worry girl
marinas Winehouse all go too much if she
doesn't have a kill I mean there's no
point
Venus don't necessarily go around just
killing other predators but isn't that
absolutely gorgeous he's staring across
at a herd of wildebeest but they're very
far away still she's still got quite a
bit of distance to travel if she's
thinking of taking on a wildebeest
there'll be a couple of youngsters on
there that'll be suited to her size
especially because she's on her own
which is typical for a female cheetah
only she's got Cubs
well Sabbats with her but otherwise this
is how you normally see female cheetah
it's the always that you'll see forming
coalition's so I was just reading a
message Jamie was saying that double
crossing which is a crossing on the
other side is completely flooded so they
aren't able to cross it at the moment so
it just goes to show how much rain that
area actually had it must have been
spectacular that side and last night why
don't know I suppose this
different areas once Burrington I was
six kilometres away and I was sitting in
the pouring rain and he had was counting
the stars so you just never know but
it's looking good for us so far
hopefully I don't jinx it and hopefully
it'll be good weather for this lovely
girl because if it does start pouring
with rain maybe she's gonna go seek
shelter who knows predators do like to
hunt in the rain too they might have a
better chance that is gorgeous to see a
cheetah
walking with rain falling in the
distance and the sky on fire it would
only get better if she heads up a bit
higher so that we can get a silhouette
shot of her let's see if we can follow
her actually I'm gonna stay oh no no
[ __ ] sorry losses caused a disaster I'm
trying to get it into low range but it's
really not the easiest there we go
sometimes force is the way forward
history with these cars now we're going
to navigate some rocks very quickly well
there's no such thing as never getting
rocks quickly that's for sure
but I want to try and
keep on the side of her
so you can get that silhouette
she needs to move up a little bit higher
there and then where it'll be perfect
try get up so we don't have to keep
moving
now any wondering of loans with Cheeta
are more successful than lions when
hunting well it depends unfortunately
cheetah and lions don't have the strike
rate like a pack of wild dogs they
really are the winners when it comes to
being successful when they hunt you know
we know she's made just made a
successful kill she killed an empire
lamb but unfortunately it was stolen for
from her how many times she has tried
before she got her hands on that in
pirate paws on that in Pilar I'm not
sure and it's it's really it's have fun
I haven't seen a cheetah kill from start
to finish I've only watched a couple of
attempts and I've seen them I've just
missed them catching things because they
were behind a tree and all something
along those lines I would say that lions
maybe have a better success rate because
they hunt in prides if it's a coalition
of male cheetah a while look at that
then then probably about the same oh my
gosh that is like an absolute dream come
true I've always wanted to see the
silhouette of a cheetah walking along
the skyline on a high ridge so there we
go I can take something off my bucket
list and I hope that all of you can take
something off too I mean we dream of
shots like this Craig give you a film
cheetah like this before Craig says no
and he's jumping for joy now so if the
camera starts to shake it's not me being
excited upon the shoots Craig this is
beautiful
I really hope we're gonna see our first
hunt shall we keep going because she's
actually caught up
well she's jumped ahead of us and I know
there's a few rocks and what cheetah
anything can happen she could spot
something
just on top of the ridge and we could be
too far behind her and all she goes
that'll be hard one to eat but but I
don't even think I had to keep up with
the cheetah while dogs yeah give you a
run for your money but I think of
cheetahs on a whole nother level so
let's see what she's going for she do
seems to be moving towards those
wildebeest there were a couple watching
yeah on this side too which is just
heading further and further up who's it
a buffalo
you were fine hind to Buffalo
see what she's gonna do now Francis from
Israel wondering if the hyenas pesky
things follow a cat's around and they do
indeed they love following leopards are
on predominantly in the sabi sand they
often feed on the same carcass and then
well cheetah they just take the kill
from them so yes a well so I'm sure that
I you know hanging around in the area
like I said I think there's a den nearby
there's a buffalo up ahead but she's not
interested in the buffalo I mean we've
seen the lines being chased around by
Buffalo cheetahs really no match you
know young Buffalo Calf perhaps not a
problem but again you've got a fight
with a big herd of buffalo and we know
how dangerous that can be so I don't
know if you would take that chance
there's a lovely cat though I think
we'll probably try and follow her for
most of the night and tall she's
successful he makes it kill let's be
optimistic here there's just stopping
the staring looking back
scanning dreaming this must be about
100,000 wildebeest just on the other
side of the Mara River quite close to
the pro- bridge so it might be a good
good spot it's just sort of head - said
she she's going towards tree I go
towards the tree whoa
turbo kicks in there but like it just
jumped
Willoughby's mega wildebeest running way
that going I'm coming here there's a
young wildebeest calf and amongst I said
I'm just gonna stop again we have seen
it with predators when they are moving
through an area will get their prey
coming into an obvious spot saying we
know that you are here don't try and
catch us because we can see you but a
cheetah can run particularly fast
she doesn't look actually showing too
much interest just yet she's just sort
of walking this is not a picnic spot of
this tree there's one young wildebeest
calf in there there could be tasty for
her I'm gonna go stand on that little
block that would be great wouldn't it
put your paws up there looking up to the
top of the tree let's see no I'm sure
there's plenty of other animals that
have st. marked up against it but no she
is coming into East RIS which I'm I'm
not sure maybe she's going to mark maybe
she'd be picking up on the scent of a
male I'd see just having a good old
smell a little beacon and from those
things she can tell who exactly has been
passed yeah I'm sure she knows the saint
of a yeah it looks like she well she's
hidden herself but I'm pretty sure the
way that she just rocked her tail that
she was perhaps ain't marking up on that
tree so may she maybe she's interested
in a potential boy that's around I can
hear the hyenas making all sorts of
funny noises down below
wildebeest are now running alongside the
cheetah that's quite cool actually
oh the scar everything is so beautiful
oh wow I mean even you can just see with
the sky behind me it's absolutely
amazing
now roshni as we drive I'm gonna try and
get another good spot yet you're
wondering about this cheater and what is
the largest size of prey that a single
cheetah could take down yeah all on its
own well for a male Chi do because
they're slightly large and again if he
was hunting by himself say wasn't part
of a coalition they take down world
Wiest I mean I've heard stories of you
know coalition's taking down adult
wildebeest I would say for a for a
single female cheetah like this you're
probably looking at a Sbarro all the
beasts would be big enough now when you
are on your own like this and we see it
in the sabi sand alight when a female
cheetah in particular or males on their
own are by themselves in the sabi sand
they would catch lots of Sternbach and
bacon it's a small meal they can eat it
fairly quickly without without too much
hassle and this is somehow you know
there's a leopard or something that's
you know maybe nearby that will come
through and see that there's zebra
there's topi there's also Impala there's
lots of game around here so we'll just
keep up with it and they would catch the
smaller things and and sort of have a
bit of chance of holding onto it you
know if you're on your own and you kill
a sub-adult wildebeest it's gonna take
you quite a bit of time to feed on that
now you've also got the worry of hanging
right in front of us is incredible of
having something harass you because it's
such a large kill so I don't know if
it's the same thing out here you don't
really see I haven't seen as many
smaller antelope species besides the
Thomson's gazelle the odd already here
and there and of course the Impala
around but not in numbers like we see in
the sand Kara let's carry on
like I said we've just got to make sure
that we try and keep up with her for as
much as we can
no we saw her smelling up against that
tree again said that the nineties tree
and I suspect that she also sent Martin
herself at the wrong name and there was
a question from RiRi about her senses on
whether she uses her sense of smell to
help her find food I think it's a
combination of things I think they use a
combination of hearing
I think cheese's eyesight is
particularly good just like any predator
that has got binocular vision and I
think that their sense of smell
definitely plays a part so I don't think
it's just one thing that they're relying
on it's a little bit of everything wow
this could be very pretty because the
wildebeest and the zebra on are
silhouetted and hopefully she heads
towards them if she heads up a bit
higher will get another silhouette oh my
goodness but even just that of the
herbivores of the back is fantastic
you can hear the classic know that of
them Pilar that doesn't even sound like
an Impala an uncle that was hopeless you
think I'd know better especially so
though the animal that we see why we see
more of every single day when we're in
the sand
doing a little zigzag technique there
aren't you girl what have you found the
scrub hear any mouths maybe lurking in
the grass that got her attention or the
scent of some sort
she definitely soldiering on though see
how everybody's just watching her not
really paying too much attention well
not yet and they're all alarming saying
hey we know you there
don't even try anything I reckon though
she finds another group of Impala maybe
some Thompson's gazelle she could go for
it okay well we're gonna carry on again
before she yeah she gets away from us
that's great though I'd said to you
before I came to the Mara that one of
the things I wanted to do was spend the
time
cheats and I unfortunately hadn't really
had the opportunity to do so because of
the high density of vehicles within the
private areas of the Cypress and and
wanting to see cheetah all the time and
because they're not particularly common
so I'm definitely going to spend as much
time as I can with this guy that just
spent some more time at the Musketeers
the rain was sort of ruined that for us
the last time all the first time I found
them unfortunately what are you gonna do
go oh you know what he's gonna see I'm
gonna make sure she doesn't go running
off to anything but look how gorgeous
that is
I told you I've been dying to get a
silhouette shot of Impala bounding
across the skyline well we won't get
that yet we'll start with the zebra and
the topi because that is absolutely
magnificent isn't there that is that is
really a postcard is it any possibility
we can have a little bit closer look so
I've got a shot for all of you that
you've got to try and get and you've got
to tag me in it because I'm not going to
take any pictures of us you you must all
just enjoy this look at that topi zebra
you've got to get all of that in and
remember hashtag safari live added to
your silhouette collection that's so
cool wait here the crown Lapwing very
unhappy with that cheetah marching
through those I don't think she'll be
particularly interested in two tiny eggs
or three tiny eggs I don't think that
would be a very tasty no you want
something a little bit more substantial
don't you but she's also smelling that
she stops and she zigzags and that's not
I don't think it's particularly hunting
technique you have never seen that
happen I know I zigzag when I walk
towards a giraffe but she's picking up
sense in the grass so maybe she's
looking for something he knows there's a
left wing okay let's go again
always a couple of Thompson's gazelle
richard joining what the success rate
for cheaters i wouldn't imagine that
it's very good very high at all maybe
slightly less than the lion but i and
not one to ask because I cannot talk
from experience I can only tell you what
the books is say because I've never seen
a Cheetah Hunt from start to finish like
I said I either get it and then they
chase and then they kill something
behind the bushes and I've missed the
whole thing because it is a lot dancer
in the circus and so my best chance is
actually here and I'm gonna be
completely honest with you because I'm
also here to learn and I said I want to
spend as much time with the cheetah in
this area so I can learn all about it
and crush those theories that people
have said things cheated do and they
maybe then I completely disagree with it
I'm just trying to I'm focusing quite
heavily now I'm also gonna quickly scan
with my binoculars as soon as see if
there's any any other prera maybe she's
just sick of it and she doesn't even
want to eat anything else tonight but I
would imagine as lean as she is that
hunger must be is setting in now so cool
this is so great
I was turning out to be a magnificent
evening but we're gonna sit you for a
little bit longer like I said I'm gonna
try not let her out of my sight and
hopefully it pays off Tristan however is
sitting or the young prince or sana I am
indeed you can see his done his book
turn around he did a little pirouette
and is now grooming the other side of
his body so no don't blend there but
that's not the place to land so it was a
thick me that came in oh and I was gonna
play a hairy casual and just kind of
lean back is that not there's a thick
knee that came flying in so that's a
water thick knee that we've got there
with a white strap on the edge of the
wing on the wing itself I'm just looking
at her Sanne probably wondering what are
you doing got a bit of a fight I was
about to learn right away hasana was and
then decided no against that but you
can't get much ganked more gangster than
that he's got the gangster lean he's
leaning up against the bank and he's
busy trimming himself he's looking super
childers laughs now inaudible did come
down
and drank and he kind of watched it but
I think he realizes inaudible is just a
bit too much for him to to grab at the
stage it's what so he was in no position
to be hunting anything from where he was
he was had to crept around the entire
edge of the dam which is near impossible
actually at this stage and given that
it's so open here that niala would have
spotted him in two seconds so he's not
gonna be able to do that hello beautiful
way look at how wonderful his eyes are
getting they almost going more orange by
the day they sort of lightining up but
going orange orange orange an
interesting Estonian tea at an almost
loo mullah eye color and those of you
don't remember Himalayas a male that
used to see around Chitra Hoffman's a
little bit into Shirley's I think he was
once or twice seen on the live drives
I'm not I haven't percent sure but he
might have been seen on safari live a
few times he had the most incredible
orange eyes and then there's the flat
rock male which has also got very
similar as to what Hassan has got so
then becoming very mesmerizing those
eyes and it's amazing that our two young
boys both have incredible eye colors so
Hassan is getting these orange colored
eyes and then on the opposite spectrum
you've got Tamil with these blue green
eyes and they both are absolutely
striking when they look at you it's
quite something they kind of both have
this this look that you get a bit
mesmerized by them so nice to see that
both the boys are going to be
good-looking lads later in life
so Lily he's saying how do I know this
lip it is there are so many names
well maybe the thing is is that it's not
so much I mean somebody with some people
use spot patterns and and will use
certain markings to kind of indicate who
exactly he is and how they tell him
apart so as far as I know Hasan is a 3/3
but for me spot patterns I helpful in
the beginning but once you see a leopard
for a long period of time you generally
kind of get a sense of who they are by
just what they look like much like you
would recognize your cattle dog that you
have at home it's the exact same thing
with these lipids as we get to a point
where we start to recognize them as
individuals just because of spending a
lot of time with him so for me Hassan is
just got a certain look about him that I
get and I know in this particular
section the young males that we see here
it really can only be her son or tumba
and they they look very different the
two of them like I say they have
different colored eyes so it's really
quite simple for to see him he's got
this kind of pinkish nose orangey
colored eyes the three three spot
pattern which is those spots over the
whiskers and that just helps to be able
to work out exactly who there are so
general so kind of appearance for me is
always more helpful in a spot pattern
because a lot of the time we see these
leopards from far away and you can't see
the spots from 20 meters even from here
I can't tell you how many spots Hassan
has got on his face but what I can tell
you is that he's about the husana look
about him which is that pink nose
there's orange colored eyes and that
general sort of roundish face that he
has a race typical cruller family face I
got stopped and muzzles and round he
faces and they are beautiful now I was
talking about Hassan is camouflage be
camouflage of that thick knee oh no it's
now stood up but it was sitting down and
I promise you it was impossible to see
and so pity it's now gone down to the
water I'm hoping it will will go back to
where it was and sit down again and I'll
be able to show you exactly what I'm
talking about
I think our husana is starting to wake
up but look at him dreaming I always
love when lipids groom their paws like
this when they have they pour out in
front and you see that long pink tongue
kind of go along the length of their
poor do is is a beautiful way to see
them
are you surveying your landscape lisanna
wonder if one day this will all be his
imagine if it does be interesting that's
for sure to definitely not be something
that I would have expected Lindley
asking what's happening - what's
happened to crude his territory and who
should get it while it's being courted
and divided and split up in chunks - all
the females in the area so at the moment
Tandi has moved made the most movement
into Korea's territory she's not taken
this whole south east corner even up I
suppose into the central parts of German
are even northwards the other day she
was seen close to befores of damn so
she's pushing quite far and taking that
whole eastern section and then shadow
seems to be taking the whole western
section at the moment so shadows being
seen along on the western boundary not
as far north as what Tandy's been going
but still pretty much the western
section is now shadows so the two
daughters have pushed in there and then
we know she only let one stage was
moving around just on the northern
section and here we go is starting to
think think about getting going just got
it alleviate some issues when we're
doing this you can see a few dark cars
in the background and interesting
the first insects that I've heard at
night since we've been in the winter it
sounds like the cicadas almost starting
to call a little bit now soft sand going
up what do you got your nose in there's
a little hole then you see he's digging
a little bit wonder what you found the
hasana
how beautiful is that there him just
creeping over the top of the damn war
just checking slinking over and if he's
just gonna sit and give us a little look
over his shoulder it would be really
nice if he did what I'm gonna do though
is I'm gonna just go back up onto the
dam wall because I want to be able to
look at that
I'll just stop there cuz he's looking
over his shoulder isn't that beautiful
that is as good as it gets when coming
to a leopard that's for sure the only
thing that could be better would be if
he just walked slightly across outside
of those branches that we've got then
sat in a nice clean part of the damn
wall that would be the only other way
that this could be any bit than what it
is right now that is absolutely
beautiful especially silhouetted against
that dark sky that we getting on the
eastern horizon almost looks like we
might get some more rain now that
there's some big dark cards coming from
the east and so he's just kind of
watching them but that's the sky that
he's under isn't that magnificent very
very pretty I know he's just watching
and checking what's going on
Megan quintessential whoo see you're
using my words now Megan certainly but
surely be teaching Megan the
quintessential ways she makes fun of me
because I use it so often pitching me
again in school it's between the
shoulder blades and ikan scratches or
it's not like us as people when we
struggle to be able to scratch our
each's that we have on our shoulder
blades it's really not ideal when we get
those itches but at least he's able to
do it when a quickly shoot around makers
I think he's going to cross parts of our
Traverse he's going to hit South which
means that we're probably not going to
see him for too much longer so I want to
try and just get up and out as quick as
possible then keep up with him and see
the last of him going over
let's try and get through the section
without killing Sims oh and myself are
you going back now the other way looks
like it looks like you might head north
now which is good news it means he might
be heading deeper back into Juma or he
could have just gone round the back of
this vehicle and then we'll turn south
from there we are you hitting no he is
turning north by the looks of things
which is fantastic means he's turning
deeper into Juma so I'm trying to just
cross this Maggie little section which
is very bouncy and I'm bouncing around
all over the place so a bit of a workout
getting over here for the old core
muscles there he goes he's just going
north and that's great news guys this is
perfect this is exactly what we wanted
we want attempted north because North
for us means that we get to see him for
longer so fantastic
it's almost time where I'm gonna have to
get my spotlight art until we're able to
put on our infrared so we'll have to
just use the spotlight for a little bit
because we don't have our infrared just
yet so it's just crossing not just yet
he's looking around is seems to be quite
varies obviously heard something that
he's now listening to and just checking
but he must keep pushing northwards he
needs to go down into the mawashi in
northwards and that will be much better
for us than if he goes south we are you
off to a sunny look so there is a little
bit kind of unsure which way he wants to
go there's a few Aramark gobblers that
are shouting at him hang on he's
creeping away any salivating as well
what have you seen hasanah that I
haven't seen you seen something
blue reckons it's tumblr that's here so
I want to go down and just see you're
gonna let somebody else go in front
because they haven't had a chance to go
and so I want to just have a look back
here because he's looking at behind this
damn wall hmm I wonder if tumblers not
here or somebody else like Tammy that
could also be another liquid that could
be around but I'm gonna go drop down
into the drainage line and just see if
he's gonna pop that side looks like he's
heading down in towards the milliwatts
he so I wanna head into the molarity and
see if there isn't another leopard
lurking that side also note in Ghana he
could also be even though he was on in
coral and cheetah Plains this morning by
now he could easily be in this direction
given the weather that we've got so I
wonder what just who is lurking because
all of a sudden there's a bit of
salivating he went into a very different
position where he was kind of stalking
lower which is a little bit of a change
so I wanna heads round in sea and we
know that there's been lots of alarm
calls around here lots of sort of audio
for birds charting and also tracks for a
young male leopard so maybe tumblr I
don't know it's gonna be interesting
nonetheless because somebody is around
that's causing husana to go into a very
different sort of mode than he what he
was for most of the are seen was kind of
relaxed and ambling along and all of a
sudden just stopped and then he started
hunting down and it's typical of either
seeing a prey item or seeing sorry or
seeing another leopard the salivating
part generally means another left or
come on windy or figure
come on come on
here we go so we just had to get windy
through the soft sand and now she'll be
okay and she'll be able to maneuver
through here just fine kicking because I
was driving here today I wanted to see
it was look like there was some sort of
tracks inside my vehicle tracks I was
wanting to see who exactly that was but
some put spider webs all over my face so
I tried get rid of those googly before
we actually look at what these tracks
are has he really crossed over no I
don't think so I think he's probably
still on this Bank
there we go who's that there's another
lipid there but it looks a course oh no
no there's another lipid yeah I don't
know who it is
is this quarantine knows that who's that
no it's wasana that's this side but how
did he get here so quickly how did you
run across so fast I don't know if maybe
there's another lipid but here is four
sauna this side it's not another lipid
this is living in a sauna so I don't
know how he got to here so quickly and
why he's facing this way now you booked
another England this one is for sauna
wood so I'm just asking the guys but
that is husana for sure
so how he got across I'm not quite sure
he must have run across in ours I don't
know it looks it's very odd because his
behaviour also as though he's watching
something decide now
yeah it must be hunting something in
this general vicinity either that or
there's another lipid lurking around
here somewhere but he's kind of run
across and now he's coming back again so
what he's seen but it's definitely
husana for sure that is him through and
through his light up his legs they give
him a bit more color what's have you
seen boy he must have chased something
this way and missed that's the only
thing I can think of because for a
second there I wondered if maybe his
older brother was around deer watching
you say he looked spooked he does
doesn't he looks as though there's
something going on and I'm not 100% sure
what's happening at the moment of it is
definitely something that's intrigued
him and like I say either he's chased
something over this riverbed and is now
coming back or he saw somebody else and
went this way and checked but I don't
see any other lipids around here like
100% sure it's a mystery what are you up
to hasanah this always seems to be
something going on with this cat win
either hand he seems to always have some
sort of intriguing stuff happening look
how beautiful he's looking though he's
really starting to fill out properly so
I for a second I thought it might have
been quarantine just because of how big
he was
Prodi's
six-years-old you want to know why he's
got black around his mouth well Cody
that's just how it is it's unfortunate
with lipids they have these markings
like this and it's all there to help
break up his face so what I assume and I
mean break up his face it's when he's
staring at an animal and he wants to be
able to be his camouflaged as possible
so he wants to hide as well as possible
and those black markings help to match
the light in the shade and make it very
difficult for the prey animal to see him
so that's why he's got black in those
areas just to make sure that it helps
keep him very well hidden from any other
of the prey animals and that he can then
hunt and stalk I have no idea what he's
doing
maybe there's a dyke or Asti invoker
that's run this direction he's now
coming back to check but he certainly
watched something or ran off to
something down here and who knows what
it was because it was another lipid we
would have found that they would have
had a face off they wouldn't have to
submit as dispersed as quickly as this
and look nice coming straight back
towards us again I'm just gonna drop my
life down as he walks towards us and you
don't go southwards though way
you can see how relaxed he is they're
just walking behind the car
typical husana maneuver okay but don't
lie down like your sister older sister
did the other day I think he's moving
down the river bid though and he is
going to sit there right I want to just
try get out of the way of the vehicle in
front of me so I mean just turn a little
bit he's still close close is he close
we're not gonna be able to turn much yet
he's still too close behind us at the
moment I thought he is a little bit
further than what he is he's literally
right behind the corn he's pull pulling
the same stunt that Tandy pulled the
other day where they sit right behind
the car don't know why they like to do
this but for some reason behind the car
is where he wants to be and so is he
going to go to the toilet looks like it
don't go to the toilet in the tire track
because in somebody's got to drive over
that and they bits of lipid dung in your
tires is never a pleasant experience it
smells quite a bit and it steams to
stick to the tires and so not very
pleasant at all what has he seen I don't
know he seems to be in a state of
undecided whether it's toilet time or
time to move on but it can't be
comfortable either way now I believe I
need to link I'm not sure to who I've
got no comms
so we'll go across to whoever it is and
hopefully it will be a beautiful
sighting any has we got back to where
those two lovely girls where they were
on the move now there's one just in
front of us and one to the right I can
just make them art at the moment so we
will be using infrared light to view
them and hopefully they're heading out
on the hunt
now I mean you can barely see anything
in front of me but you're gonna have to
believe me there's a line right there
there we go I'm looking infrared dish is
moving west and the other line is just
off to the right somewhere she can't see
her at the moment so has it got dark
they decided it was time to get moving I
think yeah I don't have to keep up with
them you'll see I have to put my
headlights on every now and then so you
don't fall in a hole or bump into a
termite termite mound
as I was explaining earlier patience is
incredibly important when you're
spending a lot of time with big cats
because they do tend to sleep a lot
Lions in particular 20-plus hours a day
the other line is gone
and she's around there somewhere there
she is having a sniff
the toy is the fun part now which one do
we stick with I think we're gonna stick
with the one wheel with initially is
just my cart and now I will flash a
spotlight every now and then to see what
might be coming ahead of the lines
nothing so far
now then he's wondering why are they
called the sausages Lily it's because
they like sausage trees so they do tend
to climb
sausage trees oh there was a jackal I
heard alarming at them it sounded quite
bless the little jackal there it is the
best a pair of them just over there and
so they might have a den close by so
that's why I just heard this bow-wow
well well they don't like lions around
their babies and the wind is picking up
I guess they're gonna take the large
awesome and the wind is picking up which
is great if you're a lioness on the head
strong winds or help mask the sounds of
them moving as you can see they're
getting right to the edge of the
infrared light so I'm gonna have to move
again
see I don't find any wolf dog holes this
evening
as I say Tristan's cat run continues so
we're gonna stick with these girls while
they head off into the darkness and
Tristan is still with one of my favorite
leopards and possibly the only leopard
who's ever stalked me on foot her Sylar
we are still with him in E and his I
don't know what he's up to he's all over
the place huh and a big jump down there
Bank hello big boy what are you doing
you he's like running around as though
there's something that he wants and
something that he's trying to hunt but I
can't see what it is so I'm trying to
just kind of reverse and stay with him
and he keeps moving up and down the bank
he's making it difficult for us to kind
of predict where he wants to go here he
comes now slowly but surely he's hitting
kind of towards where we are he comes
look at that he's almost like he's on
the prowl he is heading south so we're
not gonna have him for I reckon we'll
have him maybe for another five minutes
at the most
but don't know what he is seen and he
has decided I want to hunt it and he is
chasing things but we can't see what it
is I don't know if there's maybe a
little rodents or something that he's
seeing I'm not sure at all what are you
watching big way
they are you asking if the spotlights
are bothering him I don't think so he's
used to the spotlight so and we're going
to infrared anyway just to make sure
that we can kind of keep him without
having to worry about spotlights but
here he comes now just walking down the
road and he's going straight into little
Gary within the next five seconds I
would say really not going to be very
long at all and this he stops on the
side no he's heading straight towards
little Gary now don't know what it's
been all about this afternoon he's kind
of been he went north than you in south
than you in East than you in West and
now he's heading towards the main road
and out of our area I'm gonna try
quickly it's beautiful with him spot lit
like that isn't it hush knee you say
lipids are a lot more active compared to
lions they are and that's why I love
spending time with him the Lions are
amazing when they're active but that's
not that often at least with the lipids
you know if you spend a bit of time with
them they will get active fairly soon
and you will end up with a really kind
of interesting sighting at some point
but there we go is busy crossing into
little Gary now Oh No maybe not snide
sense marking at least going to the
toilet that is
let's just see what the spotlights just
so that you were saying if they were
worrying him you can see we're not
shining on his face so we shine down on
the ground in front of him and just kind
of bounce the light up towards him and
make sure that we're not in any way
shining in his eyes and so if he wasn't
sure about the spotlight he most
certainly would avert his gaze from them
whereas now you can see he's really kind
of not too concerned about it so just
shine in front and make sure that we
don't shine into his eyes and then
everything's okay and there he goes
that's all going to be our last views of
Hasan as he disappears into little gari
so he came from there today and well now
he goes back and he crossing exactly the
same place that he crossed this morning
coming in so back down to the south and
venturing into his territory that he had
walnut territory but his area that he
moves around down here he seems to spend
a lot of time down in the South in
little Gary these days and so kind of
bounces between the two and you can see
just how he's gonna melt into the
darkness as the range of the light gets
too far and so well hassanis links off
into the evening and disappears into the
thickets of the sabi sands and little
Gary we were talking about cats being
active and lions on as much as the
lipids but it seems Prince lions are up
and moving so let's go across to him
you know he's still with these gorgeous
sausage girls naeun see they are hungry
they're not starving by any means and
here's a apps you might have heard
something up ahead just had worked opium
zebra in this area a little bit earlier
I can we need to keep up with her again
and check where the other one is
as a retired wildebeest from when all
the baldies behind it some carcasses
strewn around this area okay I've got
both the girls I just want to get up
ahead a little bit so in case there is
something there
some giraffe coming up but to Linus's
giraffe might be a little bit big
and if there is a baby drop that they
would definitely have a gander ass
and they're moving quite quickly as you
can see that and they're really marching
now he's gonna pop up next to us and you
can see how pitch-black it is till we
put the infrared on so the grass is
quite short after the ball the beasts
have been through here so you can see
them using the slightly more bushy areas
providing a little bit more cover
listen giraffe at the head I don't know
if there's a baby with them there
Oh hold on the it's a mud to deal with
we did all the zebra disappear G lots in
this area yeah
so far ahead of them devoid of life
apart from giraffe on the horizon up
there you know walking parallel to us
just in the nice thick thick it's a
watch out the only a bit of a bump
they might have heard zebra in the
distance that we can't see it that could
be over the next little rise this is a
slightly Angela tin country here
ya know he's got both of them on the
March
you can see that front line this is
quite a bit bigger back line this looks
to be a little bit younger
winds starting to pick up even more
which is great for the Lions roshni's is
wondering what differences in hunting
strategies have we noticed between the
greater Kruger area and the Mara now one
must remember that lion hunting
strategies will vary wherever there are
in Africa I mean the lines in in in the
greater Kruger are far more proficient
at hunting Buffalo for example but
that's just because they don't have the
amount of choice for these lions D and
Jimmy it seems to be only the males and
certain prides little and by flow
normally only during the the wet season
when the volu be staunch yeah
lines are taking us off the road down
bumpy bumpy
so I mean the Lions have they've got
that the migration so they'll charge
into the migration no real stalking or
anything and just wait to see if
something happens or feza
and injured wine or lots of different
active Sam they're also quite a lot of
water hunters here so they're actually
waits around burrows but again a lot of
those tactics could even change season
me and never put put put around the
whole I mean a round peg in a square
hole was the other way around around a
square peg in a round hole because as
soon as you do that you are going to
find them doing something you say they
don't do and that's the wonderful thing
about being out there with these animals
is that their their behavior can change
and to a certain degree certain
behaviors are learned from from each
other like for example elephant hunting
in Botswana it's very much a pride thing
rather than a lion thing and it's only
in areas where they've been forced to
take advantage of the massive amount of
elephants and very little other game
during certain times of the year
I just need a mission these girls
special I'm not seeing any eyes up ahead
and aren't any so far set time to keep
up
whole
looks like they're not favoring the
roads this evening
I remember this is a hundred percent
live from the Mara in Kenya where with
two lionesses on the hunt in the
pitch-black
well if dick knee has been a day full of
cats lion leopard and cheetah so let's
go see how Taylor and her cheetah are
getting on
so cheetah has decided that she needs a
little bit of a rest which I don't blame
her for she means she ran around on she
caught herself a meal she had stolen
from her you probably who stuff quite a
bit of energy doing so and then to find
her just resting up on a termite mound
not for very long and then getting on
the move and she actually travelled
quite a distance I'm very impressed with
how quickly she covered that ground but
that's also quite typical with the
cheese's and sometimes if you leave them
in one spot you can come back 20 minutes
later and there will be kilometres away
they really really do move there was not
an uncommon sight in the sabi sand it
should be following a male cheetah from
the southern section of the reserve this
was down on the south of the sabi sand
and then within an hour's time crossing
out on the northern boundary when they
want to go they move and we see it all
the time we sit with wild dogs how
quickly they go but their Gators
normally a little bit quicker and more
constant than that of a cheetah she's
just obviously walking and it's the same
like a leopard or a lion male-line going
on a serious territorial Patrol they
also cover well areas very quickly now
even though it's completely dark Archer
and she has sat down in the long grass I
think she's just waiting for everything
to settle it's not to say that cheetah
don't hunt at night that's a big
misconception they most certainly can
hunt at night and I have sort of come
across cheetah at dusk just after the
Sun and set to feeding on animals when
we were with him you know twenty to
thirty minutes prior to that and and and
had to leave though because when you're
a guide and you have guests around we
don't have infrared cameras of course so
you have to leave a cheetah at just at
sunset no spotlighting of cheetah and no
Cubs of course as you know and things
like wild dog we don't Sparkle that
either when you spot laughs they're
nocturnal creatures so and but you'll
bump into them you know have a quick
look keep the lights off them of course
because you'll know that the hyenas will
come charging in or even a lion or an
effort and still their kills so you just
want to keep them as hidden as possible
and that's what we're doing here and
that's where we are so lucky is that we
are able to sit
in complete darkness I can't even see
how far away she is from my car at the
moment I'm just sort of guessing she's
listening to lions roaring now very very
very far away and very faint so I doubt
that any of you will be able to hear
because I'm just hearing it but there's
lines surrounding us there's lions to
the west of us is lions to the north of
us and the signs to the east of us and
these plaintive will to be surround are
they going to be on the right side of
the river I only hope so now
Ellucian you're wondering if this
cheetah could climb trees she might say
that he can she went to climb a vertical
tree you know something as tall as a
morula like in the sabi sand but most
certainly one that's been pushed over by
elephants it's one tree that's got
low-lying branches would make it quite
easy for her to climb up but she'll be
climbing trees for a completely
different reason than that of a lipid
would you know she doesn't take her
kills at trees she feeds down on the
ground but when you live in open areas
like this it's quite tough to see over
the tall grass and you can see it's
really quite high here the wildebeests
haven't been through this section and
grazed it short just yet that will
change over the next few days and so
should we be using it as a vantage point
just as we see animals using termite
mounds they will do the same thing and
it came they're actually not too bad at
getting up but the problem comes in with
lipids and not if it's with cheetah and
lions it's coming down and they don't
seem to be as coordinated as they are
when they go up that's where lipids take
the cake and of course they can go up a
tree and come down just as well but
we're gonna sit with us girl and see
what she gets up to she's not completely
flat just yet she's still pricking her
ears Tristan is not sitting in the cover
of darkness he's got his spotlight out
and I wonder what he's searching for
well just bumbling back but I've just
found tracks for there's other liquid on
top of my track from this morning and we
know that husana was at the dam the
whole morning and day so it must be
tumblr that's moving around yeah but
checking very carefully and very slowly
the last tracks I had were coming out of
the moola ROTC again right where his
tracks went in this morning and hitting
back to this general vicinity so I'm
just driving slowly and scanning around
this light trying to hope that I pick up
his eyes some way in this area but
definitely the tracks are on top of my
tracks from today which is interesting
they're not on track on top of the
tracks from this afternoon from some of
the other vehicles but they are on top
of mine from the morning which means
that he must be some way in this general
vicinity I like I say just got to find
him wherever that may be you might be
just sitting underneath one of these
bushes or maybe he's begun to move
around now and I've just missed him by
him not facing towards the spotlight
because if he's not close and he's not
facing towards me and he's dark the
ground well then I've got no chance of
spotting him but it's a good kind of
coup for tomorrow morning to come and
check on here for our little green eyed
boy and maybe he'll be around and dams
instead of a sauna in the morning hmm
interesting now as Divini a lot of lipid
movements around the milliwatts he at
the moment I wonder if the rains are
gonna change that right remember when I
first started at Safari live I didn't
see lipids in the motor water at all in
fact I think it took me about four
months until I saw my first leopard in
the Milwaukee and now in the last two
weeks I think I've seen about 40 in
there in there and it's obviously not 40
but there's been a vast majority of the
sightings have been in and around the
Milwaukee drainage section so must be
somewhere there must be something about
the dry season maybe the shade that
comes in to the area and causes much
better place for them to July down also
I suppose twin dams is a huge benefit as
well because that's water for these cats
within there's no water anywhere else
they also go up to Gary Dam so it's nice
connective kind of
to to have when you have a drainage line
that runs from one being water source to
another one it helps to be able to then
find these guys because they'll go from
one to another and back and forth and
that's why I'm sure we're seeing so many
moving around yeah but other than that
not much happening a few in partner a
one or two little scrubbers have popped
over the road while I've been driving
and there's updates at the income with
female that we had earlier she's crossed
into the West so she's gone back to
summer Mimi so I had to go rejoin the
Pride apparently they heard it calling
that buffalo herd is turning north
towards one year later which is not
ideal for us and what else is happening
that's it that's the only updates I've
got they didn't find in Ghana this
afternoon ochita Plains it seems to have
vanished lying it in with grain was
active for some part of the afternoon or
anything the whole afternoon with some
part of it it was active than was it
working and growing and so we'll try
maybe check there in the morning to I
didn't do it you're asking where are the
elephants well in this area get them up
we have weather like just us today and
so going to be pretty macaque they won't
be too many era was whether they try and
get into dense thick areas try and hide
out from the wind and the cold and so
you've received very little of it in
saran cold front but prior it was hot we
also didn't see too many until the last
afternoon before the cold when I thought
well the elephants are back now
and all of a sudden the weather changes
and that's the end of that but we didn't
have those two herds and I believe there
was a herd seen today on torchwood this
general direction so maybe tomorrow
morning you know some alias it would be
nice to have some elephants tomorrow
morning given that the wind is sickening
it looks like it's breaking up overhead
I can see a few stars and so that would
generally mean that we are going to
experience some clear where they're
hopefully warmer weather which will
drive the elephants to come and drink at
some of the water holes particularly if
the Sun is out now for those of you that
are also wondering about the penguin
tracks that I found the other day and
whether I've been checking around I have
every night's driven the same
Road to come and check for this Pangolin
every morning every night to try and see
if there's any more tracks coming back
over the road but so far there's been
absolutely nothing and it's exactly
where we are now so we're just checking
slowly along seeing maybe by some
miracle this pangolins still around it's
not going a little bit far for us to
probably expect it to be here if we
haven't found any more signs you can see
this is where it crossed that's the
market we made to indicate this area and
unfortunately if it's three four days
and no more signs chances are that it's
probably moved on a little bit and is no
longer actually in this particular
section which is a bit of a bummer but
now as the top of the year when you see
pangolins you'll find a lot more in
August September October and so their
breeding season from what I read and
they tend to be a lot more active and
they try and find one another and find
mates and so you find them kind of going
across roads and moving and looking for
each other and so it's a good type
patterns apparently August September
October is apparently the best time for
them that would be a really nice
surprise I'd be super happy oh one of
those
hmm like I say otherwise it feels a
little bit quiet Archer no sons of any
Isles no Janet's in any of the holes and
they've been checking extensively in all
of them trying to fund we tu one sedan
all in an aardvark well odd [ __ ] would
be well we do fit flat we saw an art
[ __ ] a very uncommon to see well
that's right either for them overcast
conditions they means they'll be out a
little bit earlier than normal so that
would have been a knife but also
something that we could have done but I
can't find any yet so I'm gonna check
there's a tree up ahead not too far I
might have to get a little bit of a move
on to see if I can get there in time
because we running towards the end of
show now but I'm gonna try get towards
where this tree is that there is a scopz
I'll pair that sometimes sits in it so
we'll try to find them quickly let's
just like I say get a bit of a move on
to where I need to be it's it's a tree
coming up in the distance yeah it's
actually maybe it's this one yes it is
this one so actually sorry I thought it
was the one in front but it is this one
so now I've just got to try and scan
around so it gives us cops I'll pay and
they are quite difficult to spot that's
right I can actually hear one no they're
not sure they further on today so that's
quite try and track it down quickly by
sound but it sounds like it's calling
somewhere here maybe this big tree is
actually where they are this evening
it's gonna be very difficult in this
tree to find them come on call for us
see any eyes we should get eyes quite
quickly from the spotlights so no it
doesn't seem like they're in this tree
either it's just go forward and see it
there if we can find one more big tree
somewhere in this general vicinity so
Tony you want a demonstration of how
Fuji works and we're gonna have enough
time that tape poogie so that he stays
where he is we've got to turn Fujian and
he's got a fancy little time when he
turns on so we'll try it turn him on oh
there we go
all right Bujji the stage is 6 for you
so there we go now I'm going to play
let's play an alcohol let's pay this
cops I'll since we were looking for them
but bad Fuji's got some good lands on
him you can actually hear that other
scopes Isles answering back because of
how loud it is so there we go that's poo
jeez what others birds are three here
pearl spotted let's see if it's better
than Byron's pearl spotted harlot
stop back actually PG has got a good set
of lungs that's for sure
so there we go that's P Gees debut we
will use PG more often let's put PG back
where he needs to be though so that he's
taped up back on the dashboards so he
doesn't fall but apparently we bouncing
down and unfortunately the end of the
show so from sins and myself goodbye
we'll see you all tomorrow morning on
the Sunrise Safari
you